Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und,
ja das war schon wieder hat gar nicht so lange gedauert die 75 Ausgabe haben wir hier im Blick,
und ja Raumzeit soll sich immer beschäftigen,
mit dem großen Ding da draußen und wo sie wenn ich schon überall hingereist Saturn war dabei bis zum Merkur sie will in die andere Richtung schon aufgebrochen aber eins,
hat irgendwie immer noch gefehlt,
mich die Erde selber und heute waren wir mal einen Blick werfen auf das was die Erde eigentlich so hervorgebracht hat wie wir heute das alles wissenschaftlich betrachten,
was sich hier sozusagen,
aus der Geologie und deren Erforschung in diesem Bereich in den letzten Jahren auch an neuen Erkenntnissen gewonnen hat.
Und dazu begrüße ich meinen Gesprächspartner nämlich den Karl Karl woban hallo Karl der Karl du bist ja.
Eigentlich Geologe also was das studiert Biologie.
Genau abgeschlossen.
Abgeschlossen und warum warum hast du Biologie studiert.
Also ich habe tatsächlich zwei Semester Felix studiert und die habe ich dann abgebrochen zugunsten der Geologie genau ich habe bin als,
Schüler irgendwie Science-Fiction top gelandet also ich habe mich irgendwo Raumschiff interessiert und irgendwann in der Zeit wo ich auch angefangen habe mich mit Medien und Webseiten zu befassen,
bin ich in die Raumfahrt und Astronomie so ungeschützt das wieder war ich so,
14 15 rum und habe damals ein Portal zu Raumfahrt und Astronomie mit aufgebaut raumfahrer.net gibt's auch immernoch ist so eine ehrenamtliche Community werden damals,
halt angefangen einfach Pressemitteilung von Isana Satz auf Deutsch zu übersetzen und hatten damit damals deutlich mehr als jetzt in deutschen likums Medien zurück zu dem Thema zu finden war auf deutsch,
und darüber,
relativ in wenigen Jahren so als als eigentlich Schülerprojekt das hat noch ein paar ältere dabei mit der Zeit auch Rentner z.b. auf die einfach viel Zeit hatten und Interesse an dem Thema aber letztlich ja Sohn.
Astro Weltraum Community Projekt quasi gestartet das war nicht wirklich so hart journalistisch das ist ja das was ich heute mache aber
wird jetzt sagen aus heutiger Sicht aber wir haben ja die ist die Wissenschaftskommunikation so als Schüler gestartet und damals
hat mir das sehr viel gebracht und dann habe ich aber angefangen Physik zu studieren weil ich gedacht habe ja irgendwas mit Sterne dann sollte man Physik studieren fand ich aber dann zu mathematisch irgendwann also da das,
ging über meine Fähigkeiten hinaus und ich habe mich immer mehr für die Phänomene interessiert als für die,
mathematische Beschreibung dieser Phänomene des Verfalls immer spannender irgendwas zu sehen was man anfassen kann oder was man sich irgendwie ganz konkret,
vorstellen kann oder was man zumindest anfassen könnte er sich vorzustellen ist anfassen zu können dahinter zu fliegen z.b. und deswegen war jetzt auch in dem astronomischen.
Ist ja auch eine sehr breite Palette haben mich immer eigentlich zu dieser Hardrock.
Objekte im Sonnensystem die wir kennen wo wir ja zudem die letzten 10-20 Jahre auch immer bessere Bilder bekommen haben
an mich immer am meisten interessiert und das alles zusammen hat mich irgendwie in die Geologie gebracht ich habe einfach einfach gesucht wo ich irgendwie naturwissenschaftliche Basics machen kann das ist ein G Wissenschaften,
zumindest in Tübingen wo ich studiert habe ziemlich massiv also da hat man im Grundstudium alle Naturwissenschaften Biologie Chemie Mathe.
Physik hat man alles querbeet weil das alles letztlich in diesen biologischen Prozessen die die Erde gestaltet haben im Laufe der letzten Jahren werden Rolle spielt und,
das habe ich alles gut mitgemacht es war auch alles so offenem Niveau wo man jetzt nicht total die tiefe Eintauchen muss also das war mein schönes querbeet Studium letztlich und ja meinem Studium ging es wenig um um uns alle aber ich würd sagen ich habe,
4 viele Zusammenhänge einfach aus dieser Zeit die jetzt irgendwie auch in meiner jetzigen Arbeit nach wie vor ein großer Schatz sind.
Genau jetzt bist ja als Raumfahrt Journalist im Wesentlichen unterwegs.
Genau ich habe nach meinem Studium tatsächlich bis kurz vor Ende meines Studiums gedacht ich würde jetzt anfangen ja,
jeden Tag auf welche Baustellen zu gehen und irgendwelche Gesteinsproben durchzusehen und die.
Gesteine zu bestimmen und ja oder was hat Geologen so machen irgendwo Goldsuchen vielleicht auch ein paar meiner Kommilitonen habe sowas ersichtlich gemacht.
Sind jetzt mir nach archäologie.
Ja genau aber irgendwie kam der die diese diese im Internet Medienerfahrung wieder hoch und dann gabs ein paar glückliche Zufälle dass ich,
einfach als freier Journalist konnte anfangen konnte direkt nach dem Studium zu arbeiten und das habe ich gemacht machst bis heute jetzt zehn Jahre lang.
Und ich sage mal ich beschäftige mich eigentlich mit Erde und Weltraum also quasi allem natürlich so ein bisschen mit meiner Lieblingsthemen sind nach wie vor dieser,
anpassbaren geologischen Sachen aber ich mache auch Raumfahrt weiteren Sinner bemannte Raumfahrt gelegentlich aber ich finde diese diese unbemannte explorative Raumfahrt richtig spannendste.
Keller und was hier auch im Team zusammengetan die Betreuerin.
Genau ja also das ist ein Projekt das ist ein Projekt innerhalb der Riffe Porta des ist so eine Genossenschaft freie Journalisten einfach diesen Medienwandel beobachtet haben und wir haben.
Ich fahre kein Gründungsmitglied aber ist gibt's noch nicht solange das Projekt ich habe mich relativ früh denen auch angeschlossen und das ist eigentlich nur eine Genossenschaft wo die als Plattform dient wo verschiedene Journalisten mit ihren
Spezialinteressen quasi zustoßen können das ist keine Plattform für so den Feld Wald und Wiesen Journalisten sondern eher so für die Spezialisten und addieren,
Journalisten zu nicht nur Wissenschaftsjournalisten wie ich auch Leute dem politischen Umfeld durchaus aktiv sind,
und da habe ich mich zusammengetan zurzeit mit zwei anderen sind auch zwei die Ehre Astrophysik unterwegs sind.
Und dort versuchen wir quasi auf mir eine Plattform die Community aufzubauen und einfach auch wir neue neue Modelle.
Plötzlich auch die ökonomisch funktionieren können Journalismus im Journalismus voranzubringen.
Ja das gelingt euch insofern schon als das wäre jetzt auch hierbei Raumzeit zusammenarbeiten und gemeinsam in der Zukunft neue Themenfelder finden und dass es
sozusagen auch hier der Beginn der neuen Phase bei Raumzeit wo ist ja leider eine kleine Pause gehabt das hatte viel damit zu tun das ist manchmal schwierig ist wirklich raus zu fühlen
wo passiert jetzt eigentlich gerade was wichtiges was sind so Dinge die man unbedingt noch mal abdecken und muss wo sind noch so ein paar verborgene Schätze da freue ich mich drauf dass wir die gemeinsam heben können.
Ist dennoch bleibt noch mal so zudem Raumfahrt Journalismus ist das so ein bisschen so ein,
wie wie gefragt ist ist denn das Feld dieser absoluten Spezial wissenschaftlich orientierten Journalisten Bereiche.
Also vielleicht zwei Aspekte Weltraum Themen.
Ja das Schöne an Weltraum Themen ist dass sie mit Bildern funktionieren und das dadurch haben die eigentlich so auf diesem klassischen wissenschaftsseiten oder sogar gelegentlich auf Titelseiten Jan da seine also das erste Bild von einem Schwarzen Loch ist auf allen Titelseiten,
funktioniert das bei,
anderen bahnbrechenden wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen unter Umständen schwieriger her sowas wie was man sich um human gene project Herder kann man da mal den genetischen Code so ansatzweise abdrucken oder so aber es funktioniert nicht so gut.
Ja gut bei Gravitationswellen sind dann ja auch nur artistic renditions sozusagen weil das lässt sich ja auch nicht so ohne weiteres wir sogar die.
Aber die können auch sehr schön sein ja genau.
Ja das stimmt.
Das Bild dass ich auch mit diese ganze Zeit Fiction müsste ich auch automatisch mit mit rein also das verstehe ich.
Genau das sagt vielen was aber ich weiß nicht also viele Science-Fiction hat kann ich jetzt in meinem ganz privaten Umfeld gar nicht ich glaube aber tatsächlich selbst Leute die sich jetzt nicht für
Weltraum dezidiert interessieren und sich informieren wenn die irgendwie ein tolles Bild sehen oder auch einfach sehen da ist wieder was,
entdeckt worden oder gesehen worden das ist irgendwie weit weg von der Erde das kann mir bis jetzt nicht das,
ist aber irgendwie so in der Welt die man bereisen,
können die Menschen irgendwie fassen und das sagt eigentlich auch allen was würde ich sagen.
Oder zumindest spricht spricht es die Fantasie an also muss es etwas und das auch glaube ich warum Science Fiction einfach auf die Bedeutung bekommen hat die
dies hat ja weil weil es einfach immer wieder so
die die unmögliche Welt ist die man sich dann aber trotzdem ausmalen kann und dem diesen ganzen Fantasy Bereich hat er so ein bisschen mehr so historisierend angehaucht ist repräsentiert halte Science-Fiction eben sozusagen.
Technisch ist alles möglich die Wissenschaft kann sich irgendwie alles
greifbar machen wenn man nur genannt nur lang genug Forst und daraus ergeben sich einfach fantastische Welten der anderen Art.
Genau die andere Seite deiner Frage so wie es wie schnell ist es funktioniert an meiner Erfahrung ist das eigentlich im Journalismus diese Spezialisten zunehmend immer stärker gefragt werden und wurden jetzt auch die letzten Jahre verglichen mit so.
General generell.
Aktive Journalisten Sackmann also dienten stinken Generalisten und Spezialisten die Spezialisten durchaus ein Vorteil weil gerade im Wissenschaftsjournalismus die Komplexität der Welt nimmt zu und die,
Erklärung der Zusammenhänge also es gibt einfach viele wissenschaftliche Themen die auch in die Tagespolitik,
rein spielen ja dass der Weltraum vielleicht jetzt nicht das beste Beispiel für,
aber auch da gibt es ja durchaus Zusammenhänge ja bis zu dem Punkt dass man mal,
den Leuten eigentlich habe ich mal vor irgendwie demnächst mal genau erklären müsste warum Deutschland jetzt in weltraumgesetz braucht ne also ist der liegt gerade viel in der Luft irgendwie und das.
Ja das ist das einzuordnen und auch auf den Boden zu bringen das,
viele Leute das verstehen und nachvollziehen können das ist glaube ich tut zurzeit sehr wichtig und nach wie vor sehr weh.
Heute wollen wir uns ein wenig die Zeit anschauen und zwar die geologische Zeit und.
Dahinter steckt im Prinzip der Versuch so ein bisschen zu verstehen einerseits wie der Mensch sich dieses Wissen angeeignet hat also woraus,
haben wir eigentlich woraus können wir denn eigentlich lesen diese Zeit weil wir leben ja eigentlich nur im jetzt wäre halt nur den Ist-Zustand und können vielleicht jetzt ein paar Jahre in die wissenschaftlichen Aufzeichnung zurück
schicken aber das ist ja alles vergleichsweise wenig trotzalledem gelingt es uns in irgendeiner Form Zeiträume zu bestimmen
die halt Millionen und Milliarden Jahre zurückgehen und das wird dann immer so nebenbei fallen gelassen ja das ist ja so und so lange her und so und so lange her.
Wie kam denn die Menschheit überhaupt dazu diesen Blick nach hinten also der jetzt nur der mal ein paar Jahrhunderte auch überspringt zu,
entwickeln also wann wann wann fängt denn die Menschheit überhaupt an zurückzuschauen.
Oh das ist jetzt eine sehr weit gefasste frei also letztlich würde ich sagen.
Liegt es wahrscheinlich in der Natur des Menschen zurückzuschauen und sich zu fragen wo man selber herkommt genauso wichtig wie die Frage wo man wo man hingeht ne.
Nicht mal dir nicht nicht nicht wann es angefangen hat ihn zu dressieren oder so sagen wo wo hat dann quasi die Wissenschaft oder eine eine bestimmte Form der Wissenschaft auch wirklich mal angefangen konkret in die Vergangenheit zu schauen.
Genau also was ich sagen will die so die kulturhistorische Perspektive ist jetzt nicht meine und ich denke mal da muss man wahrscheinlich ziemlich früh ansetzen,
wenn man jetzt zu Didi geowissenschaftliche passback Perspektive sich anschaut also die Geologie sicher auch eine alte Wissenschaft weiß eigentlich schon
ziemlich lange wenn ich schon immer in der zivilisierten Zeit der Menschheit wichtig war zu verstehen was das auf dem Boden rum liegt vorallem natürlich erstmal aus irgendwelchen ökonomischen Gründen dass man,
die die Rohstoffe der Erde nutzt z.b. und welche Metalle das man weiß wo wo kriege ich die her was kann ich denn damit anfangen und,
was aber auch dann das ist so er so dieser neu Gehbereich wo dann die moderne Wissenschaft sicher auch irgendwann sich immer weiter entwickelte.
Ist also man findet ja nicht nur Steine Minerale Metalle auf der Erde in der Erde sondern auch Skelette z.b.
Also die Telefone der großen Dinosaurier 19 Jahrhundert gab sicher schon vorher Funde und auch so diese alten Sagen und Mythen OZ für sowas wie Drachen Rolle spielt ist das kommt sicher
und alles sicher auch ein bisschen damit zusammen wie gesagt das ist nicht so mein Themenfeld aber ich glaube Menschen haben sich schon immer
Gedanken darüber gemacht und Geschichten ausgedacht um auch solche Funde irgendwie einzuordnen für sich und sei es dass man erstmal jetzt keinen kannte der sowas gefunden hat aber zumindest hat man diese Geschichten weitererzählen die haben sich auch über Kulturräume hinaus
verbreitet und.
Im Zuge der modernen Wissenschaften vor der Entwicklung der Evolutionstheorie durch Darwin und andere,
ging es dann ja auch darum zu klären wie ist das eigentlich es gab früher Tierarten die es heute nicht mehr geht,
und das irgendwann ausgestorben im 19 Jahrhundert wurden ja auch so die ersten großen Dinosaurier Arten beschrieben wissenschaftlicher kroat und die Frage ist also wann.
Haben die gelebt.
Verschiedene oder es gab eine Halbzeit Dinosaurier auch eine zeitliche Entwicklung und das schöne an den Dinosauriern dass auch sie eine wahnsinnig lange Zeit ich glaube es waren.
200000000 Jahre in den es Dinosaurier gab es verglichen so mit der mit der menschlichen Homosapiens Perspektive oder sage mal der der Menschenaffen im weiteren Sinne ist das,
dass das sind so ein paar Millionen Jahre letztlich Namen Vergleich also das ist eine große Bandbreite und da hat man einfach im 19 Jahrhundert schon gesehen es gab eine Entwicklung innerhalb der Erdgeschichte wo sich Arten verändert haben.
Und das ist auch irgendwie bis heute,
sehr relevant also die die paleontologie ist ein entscheidender Teil der Geowissenschaften weil die Einteilung der Erdgeschichte in Zeitalter in verschiedene Untereinheiten komplex,
in der Zeit wo es höhere Lebewesen Pflanzen Tiere auf der Erde gab komplett bis heute auf der Basis von,
von Arten gemacht wird da gibt es irgendwie die.
Das Modell eines Leitfossil das ist ein Fossil was in einer bestimmten Zeit gelebt hat und was an sehr vielen Orten in sehr vielen
biologischen sag mal biologischen Settings environments vorgekommen ist was man in der 4 geologischen Schichten heute findet dieser Zeit wo man einfach einen Finger drauflegen kann sagen ok Veranda dieses Fossil gefunden,
oder wir sind wir Fichte soundso alt oder dies zumindest jünger oder älter als eine andere und deswegen kann man das einordnen.
Und nicht selten ist ja dann auch das Aussterben dieser Art auch tatsächlich mit einem signifikanten Änderung auf der Erde verbunden.
Genau genau also das ist glaube ich der nächste Schritt und der kann deutlich später zu sagen wie sich
wie wie war die Erde zu der Zeit beschaffen oder dieser Teil der Erde damals beschaffen aber überhaupt erstmal Zusagen in der Zeit hat diese Organismus gelebt und vor allen Dingen aussterbeereignisse ist das Gute Schlagwort also das ist mit wirklichen. In der Zeit,
plötzlich eine Art verschwunden ist und das heißt wenn man eine Schicht hat und da waren die da und da war sie nicht mehr da dann kann man quasi,
diese Schichtgrenze auf einen Zeitpunkt festlegen.
Das heißt Darwin war so der erste der das eigentlich überhaupt so ins Rollen gebracht hat.
Der hat uns Rollen gebracht also darf ich war ja auch schon noch so ein Universalgelehrter ich habe jetzt nicht ganz im Kopf was der so geologisch gemacht hat er sicher auch Dinge gemacht,
ich habe mal geschaut wer das Alter der Erde so zum zum ersten Mal sich überlegt hat und.
Da muss man vielleicht also zum einen,
gab es einen denen Nicolas Steno der hat schon im 17 Jahrhundert geforscht und der hat ein Prinzip was auch bis heute universell der Geologie angewandt wird also eigentlich
klingt ein bisschen nach der Binsenweisheit dass dass das stratigraphische Prinzip dass man quasi
erstmal eine Schichtfolge hat also quasi in der Geologie gibt immer ablagerungs Prozesse irgendwas 7 von oben nach unten der Schwerkraft folgen und diese Schichtenfolge
ist erstmal,
von unten nach oben sitzen unten ist das älteste oben ist das neueste soll das kann sich natürlich verändern gerade wenn man jetzt auf der Erde ist wo es um die Plattentektonik und Gebirgsbildung mit Faltungen und da kann es auch durchaus sein dass dich Dinge drehen,
Monat 80 Grad oder sogar noch weiter wieder zurück alles möglich aber in der Entstehung ist auf der Erde gibt's dieses universelle Prinzip
das alles nicht so einschichten Ausbilders hat man schon hat dieser die Cola stehen und 17 Jahrhundert schon beschrieben und diese Idee eines Leitfossil die kommt von,
ich glaube es waren schottisch ein englischer Biologe.
Was für eines Fußpilz.
Dieses Leitfossil jetzt also dieses dieses Haus hier was zur gleichen Zeit an verschiedenen Orten auftaucht zur gleichen Zeit genau und diese Idee die hat will Smith im 18 Jahrhundert entwickelt.
Und dann spielte die Physik rein,
im im 19 Jahrhundert und jetzt können wir schon so Richtung der ersten Altersschätzung in der Erde also sicher.
Ich hatte einmal Kontakt mit diesem Kreationisten die die Bibel und das Alte Testament sehr wortgetreu auslesen sagen hat die Erde so 10.000 Jahre alt und.
Diese.
Relikt dieser religiöse Hintergründe spielen sich auch in diesen ersten Schätzungen Rolle als es gab ja auch bis ins 19. jahrhundert diese Konflikte zwischen Pluto nisten und wie sind die anderen.
Python Listen und Vulkane and the moment.
Also es gab die Gruppe von damaligen Geologen die gesagt haben die Erde ist letztlich aus aus dem Innern heraus gestaltet worden,
also die quasi es waren oft Geologen die er so in vulkanischen Gebieten gelebt und geforscht haben und dann gab es die die gesagt haben dass er Sache von von oben also,
Wasser hat die Erde z.b. gestalteten das Wetter.
Und da spielen diese biblischen Gedanken der Rollen also Richtung Sintflut der warum findet man hoch in den Anden Marine Sedimente also irgendwelche Muscheln die definitiv mal mehr geliebt haben müssen ja das muss eine Sintflut gewesen sein.
So na also diese Vorstellungen spielt keine Rolle deswegen würde ich jetzt auch dieses Jahr der Bibel jetzt nicht aus der heutigen Sicht zu oben.
Beurteilen,
damals wusste man es nicht besser nein das war so der kulturelle kulturelle background unter dem erstmal viel interpretiert wurde genau und dann kam die Physik Endspiel nämlich so die Entwicklung der Thermodynamik,
und der einer der da genannt werden muss ist der William Thomson der später die Titel Baron Kelvin bekommen hat also der Kevin von der Kelvin Skala Temperaturskala und der hat sich überlegt,
wenn die Erde mal aus einem aus dem Feuerball entstanden ist also diese diese Idee,
man kann da schon sowas wie Meteoriten und Einschläge also irgendwie ist die Erde mal aus aus Hitze entstanden warm hatte mal eine gewisse Temperatur und die ist über die Zeit abgekühlt dann kann man ja mit einfachen.
Einfacher Physik sich überlegen wie lange das dauert letztlich und der hat so I recht,
Schulrecht akurate Schätzungen des ist 20 bis 400 Millionen Jahren also es ist immer noch,
mindestens zehnmal weniger als als reale Realzins viereinhalb Milliarden Jahre aber,
das war sozusagen das damalige wissenschaftlicher wissen.
Aber im Vergleich zu 2000 Jahren jetzt der Kreationisten auf jeden Fall schon mal einen Schritt nach vorne.
Genau durchaus.
Ja mein Mann muss ich überlegen was wie datiert man weiß also wie kann man irgendwie da die Jahre zusammen zählen also in dem Verfahren was das bedeute angewendet wird und auch damals schon angewendet wurde,
Dendrochronologie wenn man guckt sich und wir Holz an von alten Baumstämmen und zählt einfach mal Ringe und gerade jetzt wenn wir jetzt heute nicht so alte.
Altes Holz hat dann kann man das irgendwie sich richtig angucken ob das jetzt irgendwie 150 Jahre alt ist Eiche Materialist oder.
500 Jahre oder sowas da muss man halt gucken gibt bessere Jahre und schlechtere Jahre es gibt es dickere und dünnere Ringe und dann gibt es einfach ein Muster je nach Standort was man dann auch abgleichen kann mit anderen Standorten.
Weil wenn ja irgendwann auch auf zu wachsen das heißt wenn der Baum lange rum lag weiß man er ist nicht wie alt er ist
kannst du dann anhand der Abstände also anhand der spezifischen Abstände im Vergleich mit anderen wo man schon weiß das Pattern finden und dann weiß man wo man ansetzen.
Genau diesen Barcode nicht man hätte um die Barcodes gegeneinander und dieses mit dem absoluten Verso-S dem relativen alter das ist auch so ein.
So ein Grundprinzip der Geologie dass man eigentlichen Geowissenschaften fast immer nur relative Altersangaben hat also man weiß,
das mit den Schichten wollen da man weiß irgendwie diese Schicht so und so in der haben die und die Dinosaurier gelebt oder bestimmten Muscheln die dann irgendwann ausgestorben sind und dass er drüber gelebt und das hat runter gelebt so ne also ich kann
finde keine Baumringe die in diese Zeit zurück reichen z.b. in die,
Trias als die erste Dinosaurier gelebt haben aber ich kann halt sagen was vorher etwas hinterher war.
Diese Beschreibung von verschiedenen Zeitaltern die ist einfach schon seit seit dieser Zeit seitdem seit dem 19 Jahrhundert eigentlich bis heute.
Beibehalten bis auf wenige Ausnahmen aber die Grenze zwischen diesen Zeiten in absoluten Zeitwerten also soundsoviel,
5,8 Millionen Jahre oder so das hat sich verschoben und das verschiebt sich bis heute letztlich.
Geräteserie kann man mit dieser Dendrochronologie gut 10.000 Jahre zurück schauen.
Okay ja das hätte ich jetzt.
Ja also zumindest gibt es hier ein Jahr in den Hohenheimer jahrringkalender und der schafft es dann irgendwie 12483 Jahre,
zurück,
bis 10000 Standard 80 vor Christus was ja schonmal ganz interessanter Punkt ist wenn man mal mit Kreationisten diskutiert die sich ja sonst ehrlich in meiner Fehlbarkeit modernere Technologie aufhängen aber so Jahresringe,
vereinigten relativ einfach zu verstehen das Konzept.
Gibt noch einen Verwandten Ansatz die man machen kann in Gletschern die in Regionen liegen wo es Vulkane gibt also wenn man jetzt auf Island ist.
Island gibt's jetzt noch nicht so lange ne paar Millionen Jahre.
Relativ junge Insel eigentlich aber seit es Island gibt gibt's da viele aktive Vulkane und man kann halt auf Grönland die großen Eruptionen von Island sehen in Eisbohrkern na und wenn man jetzt dann muss man sich angucken.
Alters als erschütterungs Mutter oder.
Nee es ist es ist die seit dieser tefra also diese Asche die damals 2010 auf den Flugverkehr lahmgelegt hat und das hat der weite Teile,
unsere himmelsfähre quasi betroffen ja diese diese feine Arsche die kann wahnsinnig weit bei großen Ausbrüchen wahnsinnig weit reisen und,
Gletschereis ist ja auch was dynamisches ne also es schmerzt immer was ab bis geschneit immer was drauf in bestimmten Regionen und das Vlies mit der Zeit zu hangabwärts und es ist in Grönland auch so und es gibt Regionen es fließt es sehr sehr langsam also in der Mitte von so einem
aishite von Samsung maisschild m und wenn man daneborg entzieht kann man über große Zeiträume also ein Antarktis ins glaube ich
bis zu 400.000 Jahre zurückgehen,
was im menschlichen Maßstab ist lange im geologischen ist nicht so lang aber da kann man dann auch wieder so ein Barcode aus hellen und dunklen Bereichen und die dunklen Bereiche sind Vulkanausbrüche da muss man nur auch wieder gucken,
wo waren diese Vulkane was für andere Quellen der Datierung habe ich um das zu korrigieren also anderer Eis Ablagerung,
bei der Arktis ein bisschen schwierig da gibt's zwar auch aktive Vulkane aber sonst ist ja nicht soviel drumrum.
Aber auf Island wird dass z.b. sehr viel gemacht.
Faszinierend 400000 Jahre okay und seit wann war das man da alles drauf gekommen auf die Nummer mit dem Burgherrn ist auch noch nicht so lange oder.
Das weiß ich nicht aus dem Kopf ich würde aber sagen das ist eine Frage der Bohrtechnik also dass man einfach diese
diese Eisbohrkerne ziehen kann
die müssen ja quasi ungestört sein also müssen irgendwie Heil hochkommen und wann musst du dann noch aufbewahren können also will sie ja dann nicht unbedingt vor Ort untersuchen sondern auch mitnehmen und kühlen
und archivieren also das ist sicher eine Sache des der zweiten Hälfte des 20 Jahrhunderts würde ich sagen.
Ja ist egal 32er wurde ein bisschen mit angefangen aber so richtig losgehen sein würde ich erst so 50-60 die Zeitraum liegst du richtig.
Genau ich hatte den Lord Kevin erwähnt und der dessen Schätzung von diesem bis bis 400 Millionen Jahre für das Alter der Erde was der nicht wusste,
ist dass es was die Quelle für für Wärme aus dem Erdinneren ist und er hat halt gedacht es ist diese anfängliche Wärme die der Erde hatte und
mit der Entdeckung der Radioaktivität so um die um die Jahrhundertwende in 20 Jahrhundert einfach gesehen es gibt beim radioaktiven Zerfall.
Im erinnern und das ist eine ganz erhebliche Wärmequelle ist es ist die wichtigste Wärmequelle aus dem Erdinnern das macht was was ich deutlich mehr als die Hälfte aus von der von der Wärme die nach oben kommt von unten.
Und das ist vor allem der Zerfall von.
Kalium Uran also das sind so die zwei hauptsächlich am vor einem vor dem kalium ist ein sehr wichtige Quelle.
Und dieser da kann man sich angucken welche,
wie die Verteilung von Elementen im Erdinnern ist ja kann es auf der Basis abschätzen und dann guckt man sich noch die Halbwertszeiten an,
und auf der Basis kann man also dieses dieses
wenn man den Wärmestrom ist ja aus dem Meer tinder nach oben kommt kann man auch auf das Alter der Erde so ein erster die Augen schließen und dann kommt man schon dann in den richtigen Bereich.
Aber das sind jetzt Prozesse die für dich im Kern stattfinden.
Das sind Prozesse die an verschiedenen Orten der Erde
stattfinden und der Erdkern die als die Erde hat er diesen differenzierten aufbauen bei also in der in der Junge Entwicklung der Erde gab es ja eine Aufteilung von
und sich die chemischen Elemente sind bisschen aufgeteilt was damit zusammenhängt dass die Erde war.
Man bei aus Magma eigentlich und in so einer Schmelze gibt es einfach.
Na, da kommen ja eh gleich noch mal drauf die ganze Struktur aber nur jetzt Bezug auf diese Radioaktivität also weil man Radioaktivität ist hältst wenn wir sie so viel Hitze erzeugen kann dann könnt ihr auch die radioaktive Strahlung an sich ja.
Du bist ja dann ja auch gemessen werden oder bzw auch einen Einfluss auf uns haben,
hatte aber offensichtlich nicht in dem Maße deswegen ich davon ausgegangen dass es relativ weit im Inneren stattfindet wo.
Und dann diese Strahlung selber jetzt nicht mehr sehr viel anhaben kann aber wegen die Hitze quasi indirekt spüren durch Vulkan aus.
Na ja die Erde ist groß und die kann jetzt nur noch außen abgeben das heißt das ist einfach also verglichen mit der mit dem Volumen ist die Oberfläche der Erde relativ klein und diese.
Am Elemente die die Hitze erzeugen sind also gerade Uran z.b. ist es hauptsächlich in der Großstadt in der äußersten Schicht auch,
und in in den tieferen Schichten gibt's dann auch andere Prozesse die noch wärmer als Zeugen können aber so in der Bilanz ist tatsächlich als ich weiß nicht ob die Wärme hauptsächlich aus der größte kommt aber die größte also die äußerste Schicht ist da relevanter Faktor,
aber es ist die diese radioaktiven Elemente sind halt trotzdem ja stark verteilt und wie gesagt es geht doch nicht um die,
Strahlung sich die ionisierte Strahlung das ist ja letztlich alles absorbiert durch den festen Gesteins Körper sondern die Wärme die bei diesem Prozess entsteht und die muss irgendwo hin und die kann.
Also wir sind also wenn zusammen die Schale vor der Strahlung bewahrt aber die Wärme kommt halt trotzdem durch in Form von Vulkanismus TA.
Ja in Form von das ist ein Extremfall mit dem Vulkanismus ist einfach wenn man wenn man Loch in die Erde bohrt und das muss nicht tief sein 100 m oder so.
Nö da wird auch nicht warm aber da hat man konstanten Wärmefluss
was ist nicht auf dem Kopf wie hoch der ist aber sozial man man ist sich sicher in diesen Tiefen dass die Sonne keine Rolle mehr spielt ne also man hat ja wenn man ganz flach am Boden ist irgendwie so ein jahreszeitlichen Rhythmus und in der gewissen Tiefe kann man einfach ein Wärmestrom Messen der von unten kommt.
Und dass die Temperatur jetzt noch nicht hoch in 100m aber es gibt messbaren Wärmestrom und der kommt von innen.
Alles klar also die Radioaktivität hatte Calvin nicht auf den Zeiger und deswegen haben seine Berechnungen sozusagen bis in die falsche Richtung gezeigt aber grundsätzlich hat er schon richtigen Riecher.
Dass man sozusagen an der Ninja thermischen Abkühlung auch etwas ablesen kann.
Genau das war auf jeden Fall guter Ansatz.
Plötzlich ist diese physikalische Beschreibung die jetzt von von calvin aus geht die mündet jetzt ein sozusagen in dieser Entwicklung des 20 Jahrhunderts in der.
Wie passiert es also da sind sozusagen diese modernen Geowissenschaften gegründet also das Studium ist er auch,
lange Zeit Geologie und irgendwann also zumindest in der deutschen Nomenklatur wurde es umbenannt Geowissenschaften Weimarer festgestellt hat es geht nicht nur darum
wie Steine und Minerale und was was was ist da so drin sondern irgendwie so dieses ganzheitliche wie wie ist es entstanden wie hat sich beim pluswert ist verändert durch Vulkanismus durch Hitze durch alles mögliche
und in diesem Zuge haben sich so verschiedene Möglichkeiten ergeben.
Alter noch besser einzuschätzen und,
achso so Zeiträume zu abzuschätzen und und und zu beobachten.
Also jenseits der Dendrochronologie als iterative schon hatten und der Eisbohrkerne was was was ist da noch entstanden.
Also Radioaktivität im weiteren Sinne war auch dafür wichtig dass man verstanden hat dass es physikalische sagt man atomare Uhren im Gestein gibt es funktioniert vor allem bei.
Gesteinen gut die vulkanisch worden sind man hat also z.b. als die Erde entstanden ist hat man.
Einen Körper der besteht aus einer Zusammensetzung von Material die endet sozusagen die mit dem Urzustand des Sonnensystems und diese diesen Urzustand den kann man quasi berechnen also was.
Wie,
wie die Verteilung verschiedener Elemente und auch Isotope = Elements waren und da gibt es bestimmte.
Isotrope z.b. Kalium-40 ist ein radioaktives Isotop hat eine gewisse Halbwertszeit liegt in dem Fall bei 1,2 Millionen Jahren,
und wenn man jetzt unters zerfällt zu einem stabilen Isotop das heißt man hat am Anfang von Entstehung eines Gesteins,
einfacher sender erstmal ein Reservoir an Kalium-40 und mit der Zeit zerfällt es zu 41 das heißt ich kann das Verhältnis von Kalium 40 zu 41,
ausrechnen und wenn es ungefähr im Bereich dieser Halbwertszeit liegt also die Halbwertszeit noch nicht völlig abgelaufen ist mehrfach kann ich sagen wann dieses Gestein entstanden ist und das gibt's diese diese
molekularen isotropen Uhren gibt es halt für verschiedene Zeiträume und die gehen bis in Zeiträume von Milliarden Jahren also Oran 200
35 und 238 Mieterverein auch zu stabilen leise drucken und damit kann man auch so sehr lange Zeiträume,
erfassen so das ist ein Beispiel jetzt aus dem aus dem mathematischen Bereichen also Gesteine die ich quasi in vulkanischen Prozessen entstanden sind das.
Beispiel was jeder kennt ist C14 die C14 Methode da wo man also quasi organisches Material datiert,
und wo man das Alter von Fossilien z.b. bestimmen kann wo einfach n.
Ein Ausgangs Verhältnis von diesem radioaktiven Kohlenstoff 14 Isotop,
von Issum mit der Zeit wenn es von der Umwelt abgeschlossen ist da werden Teil davon und Außenverhältnis kann man dann auch wieder das mal auf das Material schließen also gibt sehr viele un,
Isotopen Uhren die man quasi gefunden hat und wo man angefangen hat.
Verschiedenen Prozessen im Ärzte Steam Zeitstempel Aufzug.
Nur zum Verständnis weil er vielleicht nicht jeder folgen kann so Isotope sind quasi sonder Varianten von Atomkernen wo wo sich das Verhältnis von Protonen und Neutronen im Atomkern ändert.
Die kommt woher.
Also Isotope sind Atome der gleichen Kernladungszahl wo es verschieden viele Neutronen im Kern gibt genaus ist das was du gesagt hast glaube ich ne.
Ja und sowas also wo kommen die her also warum gibt's die.
Es gibt von allen Elementen verschiedene Isotope.
Und manche also wo kommen die ursprünglich her.
Da muss man wieder noch mal ganz am Anfang anfangen ja die unser Sonnensystem ist ein Produkt eines Uhr Nebels also da als die Sonne sich zusammen weilte und immer mehr zusammen drückt und dieser Urnebel,
wo das alles herkommt ist das Produkt einer Supernova.
Und so eine Supernova ist wie so ein Startknopf ja also da der erzeugt man quasi Marteria einer einigermaßen gut durch physikalische mathematische Modelle,
beschreibbare Zusammensetzung von verschiedenen Isotopen und das muss man sitzen rein rein nehmen in diese diese Berechnung letztlich.
Also zu seinem Material was für immer da war und in dem Fall kann man aus dem,
radioaktiven Zerfallsprozess dieser Isotope relativ klare Schlüssel ziehen auf die auf die Zeit warum kann man das bei dieser Radiokarbonmethode C14 für Lebewesen so genau machen.
Oder organisches Material.
Das liegt daran dass alle organischen Materie die im Austausch mit der Atmosphäre ist,
einen definierten Wert von C14 zu dem stabilen,
Kohlenstoff C12 hat das Verhältnis von dem radioaktiven zu dem stabilen ist konstant weil wir uns ständig mit der Umwelt ja austauschen durch Stoffwechselprozesse und dem Moment wo wir sterben.
Ist dieser Austausch weg und das C14 Reservoir singt.
Deswegen kann man einfach gucken ok ab wann hatte sozialen Sehprozess eingesetzt und dann, relativ genau auf die Zeit bisher schon revolutionär.
Genau das hat denke ich vieles,
zu ändern also da hat angiologische Betrachtungen plötzlich diese Zeitstempel bekommen,
aber was glaube ich ob es heute total wichtig ist und auch im Sonnensystem wo wir noch zukommen wichtig ist es eigentlich diese relative Zeitskala also das man auch einfach immer immer wieder gegen checkt kann das sein,
dass das jetzt so alt ist und das andere Jünger,
und da gibt es auch verschiedene Methoden also eine der schöne die ich mir rausgesucht hat das hat man in den 50er Jahren festgestellt dass es
Plattentektonik gibt also der alfred-wegener hatte zwar die Idee der Kontinentaldrift trifft in den in den 20er Jahren schon aber er war ja kein Geologe und deswegen hat er keine Chance gehabt,
das in den,
geologischen Kanon einzubringen und es gab bisher den 50er Jahren völlig verschrien Kontinentaldrift als als Theorie zu erfolgen da wurden teilweise Jungforscher gekündigt wenn sie das getan haben und da öffentlich drüber gesprochen haben.
Seehofer.
Und da gabs eine Biologin die eigentlich auch nur Geologie studieren konnte,
weil während des Zweiten Weltkriegs in den USA wenig männliche Studenten DaWanda in der Zeit war konnten Frauen nur in die so amenities na also die in die weicheren Fächern man.
Geologie recht hartes Fach Hardrock.
Genau die kam halt da rein und hatte letztlich auch nicht wirklich eine Anstellung aber hat mit einem Geologen zusammengearbeitet und.
Und der Wade zu sagen hat hat Proben genommen von der Radar sola Erkundung der Ozeanböden damals hat man mit Kriegsschiffen der US-Marine dies Ozeanboden quasi aufgenommen und dann,
hat er so Muster gefunden und und aufgezeichnet und sie hat eigentlich als erste erkannt und dann auch ihren ja,
Sackmann Dr Vater am Ende dazu angestiftet es auch zu saugen dass dass sich wirklich die die Ozeane immer weiter,
aufhalten das war also die sie ihr Name ist Marita führt sagen Sie es eine der wichtigen Wegbereiterin so der modernen,
Geowissenschaften und auch der der Anerkennung der Plattentektonik im 20 Jahrhundert.
Mariensee.
Karpador Anti-Age ap&m.
Kindercamp viel mehr Leute ich finde es ein bisschen traurig.
Das ist immer das Problem in der Wissenschaft dass die ins Beiträge der Darm nicht in demselben Maße gewürdigt werden da gibt's sehr viele andere Beispiele aber es ändert sich lang.
Ja und also worauf ich hinauswollte im Bereich Datierung ist dass diese Ozeanböden z.b. im Atlantik Gerda der bildet sich mit die ozeanischen Rücken in der Mitte gibt's diesen Brücken,
Zeichen zweigeteilter Rücken in der Mitte ist ein Graben da wo es immer weiter aufgeht,
und da gibt es sozusagen immer neue vulkanische Kruste also veganisches Gestein und das Wandertour über die Anionen nach außen,
sowas von dieser Linie die mittelozeanischen Rücken nach außen und irgendwann nach 404 und dutzenden Millionen Jahren singt es irgendwann ab in so einem,
Internet obduktions Zone wo ist dann in den Erdmantel Absinth
und wenn man sich jetzt diese Gesteine kann man sich angucken und morgen im Uwe und runter tauchen und sich das angucken es gibt auch Gegenden Wien Island wo man das teilweise auch an Land haben sich angucken kann man stellt fest dass sich,
dass man eine Richtung des Erdmagnetfeldes also eine Polarisierung des Erdmagnetfeldes in diesem Gestein.
Verstehen kann und,
die ändert sich über die Zeit über die Jahrmillionen also wenn man so einem mittelozeanischen Rücken Einrichtung von der Mitte entlang fährt sieht man immer mal dass der magnetischen Nordpol mal im Süden la, Norden, Süden und Mum Norden und wieder sind Barcode.
Das sind quasi die magnetischen Regime des Erdmagnetfeld und.
Man hat wieder so eine so eine Maßgabe dass man sagen kann so das ist jetzt.
Z.b. eine längere Epoche wo oder Süden magnetische Südpol oben war und eine kürzere da war es unten und so weiter und das kann man mit allen Gestein auf der Erde korrelieren die.
Man hatte Spritzen entstanden sind also aus dem heißen Gestein letztlich.
Das hat gesagt mal wieder so ein Barcode aber diesmal ein Barcode mit dem man wirklich viele Millionen Jahre zurückblicken kann ja ja.
Ja
Dann hast du jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt.
Also verstehe ich das richtig dass das jetzt diese diese Methode dass man so sagen jetzt mal den ich nächstes mal den Magnet Barcode quasi herausgefunden hat dass ein das jetzt eigentlich erstmals wirklich in die Lage versetzt hat wirklich,
einen anfangen zu blicken oder zumindest sehr viel weiter als bisher.
Oder war das nur mir so eine Bestätigung von etwas aus man sich auch schon anders erarbeitet hat.
Also es ist eine Hilfe alter einzuschätzen aber das hat eine Grenze.
Das heißt wir können jetzt ja alle festhalten,
an dieser Stelle hatte die Menschheit sozusagen die Geowissenschaften so weit entwickelt dass man ein extrem gutes Rüstzeug hatte um überhaupt erstmal eine Vorstellung davon zu bekommen was,
was ist denn eigentlich unsere Erde also man man Busse wie große sie ist und all diese Dinge man konnte viele Dinge datieren aber jetzt könnte man sie mittlerweile so gut der Tiere nachmalen vielleicht war noch nicht alles weiß.
Aber man hatte zu miss meinen Clan Blick und absolut auch unverrückbare Erkenntnis da drüber der Dinge ist aber mal ein paar Milliarden,
Jahre alt und da ist eine Menge passiert und das hat irgendwie viel mit Vulkanismus zu tun,
und oben an der Größe da tut sich natürlich alles sehr viel in filigranen Schichten und je nachdem wohin man jetzt eben blickt entweder ganz tief,
am Ozean graben oder eben oben in die unterschiedlichen Sedimente der größte
kann man unterschiedliche Einblicke in diese Welt rein bringen und sie vor allem auch relativ stabil und zuverlässig miteinander in Relation bringen und damit aus der viele relativen Messer rein dann im Prinzip uniglobale Zeitskala
entwickeln also im Prinzip ist das jetzt hier schon mal so,
diese geologische Zeit von der wär eigentlich sprechen wie sie sich jetzt quasi im erkenntnissystem des Menschen erstmal herausgebildet hat.
Genau das ist kann man sagen.
Diese biologische Betrachtung der Zeit der Erde hat ein Entscheidungsproblem und auf die wollte ich gerade sprechen kommen also wenn wir gerade noch mal diesen Ozean wurden sich anguckt der Wirt,
von mittelozeanischen Rücken kommend,
und wenn er nach außen wandert der wird immer schwerer Herr weil irgendwie es regnet Sediment von oben drauf sodass es braucht ja über Jahrmillionen kommt da einiges zusammen und da gibt's einfach eine natürliche Grenze oder so schwer ist,
dass der also schwer ist in dem Fall auch dicht wird dass der so dicht ist das.
Einfach ab sind ja der wird bis dann quasi plötzlich dichter als dann dieses Mantelmaterial was runter ist und das heißt irgendwann entsteht,
von selbst eine Subduktionszone und diese Grenze liegt bei 180 Millionen Jahren also 0,2 Billiarden also das ist.
Also Situation ist total wo das Material dann wieder in den Erdmantel eintaucht.
Genau das ist also dieser dieses Barcode musste der magnetischen Epochen des Erdmagnetfeld das ist schonmal einen ziemlich verglichen mit dem Alter der Erde ziemlich kurzer Zeitraum die man sich an.
Okay nur nur 180 Millionen Jahre.
Nur 180 also aus menschlicher Sicht kann man immer lachen da aber aus biologischer Sicht ist es ist es nicht die Welt.
Und kann man noch tiefer gucken.
Natürlich also man kann.
Über diese Leitfossilien kann man relativ weit zurück gucken in Zeiten bis in Zeiten in denen die ersten Fossilien abgelagert worden sind,
ein ein guter. Wo es wohnt quasi alles wo diese diese Einordnung Mitleid verstehen sehr leichtes weil das Leben schon sehr verbreitet war auf der Erde ist das Kambrium.
Kambrium ist so eine Zeit.
Vor ungefähr 540 Millionen Jahren da haben wir schon mal zweimal mehr oder fast dreimal mehr und das ist die Zeit in der die ersten Skelette im Bauplan des Lebens erschienen sind.
Knochen,
super ab Lagerungsbedingungen landet irgendwo much kann alles weg faulen was sonst sein Fleisch dran war aber die Knochen bleiben und Knochen kann man auch heute mit paläontologischen wissen gut dann einer Zeit zuordnen.
Aber 540 Millionen Jahre ist auch nur ein Zehntel erdgeschichten also wir haben sozusagen ne es gibt ja diese,
diese Analogie weiß immer so schwer fassbar ist auch mit der Urne also wenn man irgendwie sagt die Erdgeschichte dauerte einen Tag.
Dann ist der Mensch seit 3, 6 Minuten da die Dinosaurier sind vor 22 Minuten ausgestorben die.
Die ersten Einzeller gab es vor 7 Stunden.
Die ersten Mehrzeller gab es vor vor 3 Stunden und die Fotos sind hier so vor 13 Stunden,
erfunden worden und zusammen mehr als die Hälfte war fast die Hälfte dieses Tags war die Erde einfach müde und leer also die Geologen sprechen auch vom.
Hadaikum und dem.
Da fällt mir gerade nicht ein aber der spielt um wieder Hades eine Rolle also die Erde war wahrscheinlich heißt so aber da gibt's dann auch keiner genaueren Einteilungen so dieser ersten 23.
Vier Milliarden Jahre und das ist ja so ein bisschen also das.
Ich glaube Fipsi Geologe außer bisschen unbefriedigend da da gibt's einfach im Bereich der ja auch durchaus relevant ist aus der Sicht des der heute belebten Erde weil irgendwie in der Zeit.
Das Leben die Erde so gewandelt hat dass bestimmte Dinge möglich wurden.
Also nur ein paar Beispielen also die die ursprüngliche Erde bestand wahrscheinlich dir die Atmosphäre bestand wahrscheinlich überwiegend aus CO2 und.
Da gabs halt irgendwann war die Erde kühl genug dass ich die Ozeane gebildet haben also sowas wie Niederschlag und dann haben sich.
Höchstwahrscheinlich das kann man auch auf Basis von Sedimenten sich angucken also.
Da gab es eine Zeit wo man sehr viele banded iron formation von meistens findet es so ganz massiver,
die Sonne Erdgeschichte auch nie wieder kam war so ein einmaliges Ereignis und das hängt wahrscheinlich damit zusammen dass es einer ehrlichen Zeit bestimmte Mikroorganismen gehabt die.
Andere Energiequellen hatten als wir Sauerstoff z.b. sondern eher md4 Methan.
Produziert haben genau also nicht als Quelle sondern sozusagen als als aus Stoffwechselprodukt Methan produziert haben es gab eine Phase wo die app,
werde erstmal sehr Methan Erdatmosphäre sehr mit Hanreich war und irgendwann gab es Organismen die dann,
auf Basis dieses Methans Sauerstoff produzieren konnten und die haben dann irgendwann überhand genommen und haben die Sauerstoff
Atmosphäre geschaffen und das ist alles passiert und diesen ersten drei Milliarden Jahren Yavuz einfach sehr genaue Vorstellung davon gibt
die ersten Strukturen die sowas wie,
Fossilien aussieht das sind diese Stromatolithen die sind so dreieinhalb Milliarden Jahre alt,
da gibst du von da aus Grönland und aus Australien.
Und das sind so übereinander gelagerte Schichten von so Matten also,
kann man sich angucken bei kein Mikroskop für und ähnliche Strukturen machen Mikroorganismen in der heißen trockenen aber
Wasserhahn also z.b. am Meer Region machen ist bis heute findet man auch in Teilen der aus australischen Küste in der Wüsten auf das Klima ist findet man die bis heute und man glaubt es
es damals ähnliche Strukturen gab aber dennoch also dreieinhalb Jahren Jahre und da kannst du trotzdem immer noch.
Drei Milliarden Jahre seither bis dann so die ersten komplexeren Lebewesen.
Sich eingefunden haben.
Das muss ja erstmal die ganze Basis dafür gelegt werden dass das Leben wie wir es heute kennen überhaupt möglich geworden ist also am Anfang hab's noch nicht mal den Sauerstoff.
Genau.
Jetzt wolltest du ja schon mehrfach.
Ist alles wischen.
Install entwischen genau und es hat natürlich auch seinen Grund warum man das jetzt hier bei Raumzeit diskutieren weil
einerseits das heißt natürlich über die Erde lernen heißt dass ich auch viel über mögliche andere Planeten zu lernen bis usw das wissen kann man natürlich entsprechend dann anwenden um dann eben die Geologie und damit natürlich die Entstehungsgeschichte des Mars und anderer,
sparen besser zu verstehen aber sozusagen das ganze Spiel natürlich auch eine Rolle in so auf so einem
kosmologische neben der Weiber natürlich auch sehen andere Sonnensysteme gibt es zuhauf ohne Ende fast fast jede Sonne,
hat auch Planeten,
jetzt mal zurückspulen mal sozusagen auf die eigentliche Entstehung unseres Sonnensystems was ja schon gesagt ging irgendwie,
vermutlich los mit einem dicken Knall weil halt einfach irgendein anderer Stern erstmal
explodiertes das scheint ja auch schon Zyklus zu sein
kosmologischen Geflecht des alles was irgendwie da sich mal zu Stern zusammen findet auch irgendwann mal wieder etwas anderes übergeht Supernova ist halt eine Variante davon die schwarzen Löcher hat mehr in der letzten,
Versendung auch schon.
Und das Besondere super nur weiß ja nicht nur dass alles wieder neu gemischt wird sondern dass er in dem Zuge auch war viele Elemente überhaupt erst entstehen weil am Anfang war eigentlich nur,
Wasserstoff und dann erstmal die ganze Weile dann nichts und Helium entstand dann in diesen Sonnen aber es.
Die die normale Kernfusion der Sonne so gibt ja nicht genug her was muss er wieder große Knall kommen damit auch Goldkettchen Träger geben kann.
Wieso unser Sonnensystem denn so entstanden und wo kommt die Erde her.
Wo kommt die Erde her ja also ich weiß nicht ob wir jetzt an die richtige Stelle gespült haben aber vielleicht springe ich gleich noch mal in die in die menschliche explorations Geschichte.
Vorstellung die jetzt auch schon bisschen älter ist es schon es gibt sowas wie Gasnebel Gas und Staub Nebel im Sonnensystem gemein auch schon mit kleinen Teleskopen beobachten kann und,
die Ballen sich irgendwie zusammen und im Zentrum entsteht ein Stern da gibt es.
Letztlich verschiedene physikalische Gesetzmäßigkeiten Prozesse die dazu führen dass um diesen Stern des Restmaterial sich in einer Scheibe zusammen bald sind diese protoplanetare Scheiben,
das war damals also Mitte des 20 Jahrhunderts nicht mehr als den Modell weil gerade dieses Wissen dass es da draußen viele andere Planetensysteme gibt die ist ja ziemlich jung also die hat man,
das hat man ja damals noch nicht wissen können man hat sich ja vermutet beim auch schon wusste dass es viele Sprecher zu von 50er 60er Jahren das man wusste das ist viele Galaxien gibt und es ist jetzt nicht ganz unwahrscheinlich dass es
auch bei anderen Sternsystem Planeten gibt aber die Technik die astronomische Beobachtungs Technik war noch nicht soweit.
Nichtsdestotrotz klar man wusste es ist plausibel dass ich aus solchen Gasnebel die man beobachten kann auch.
Sterne und Planetensysteme bilden und letztlich konnte man lässt sich gut beschreiben wie
es durch verschiedene Stöße und Kollisionen und Zusammenballung in diesem System da gab es dann diese Planetesimale RS na also ist es etwas kleinere Staubpartikel die zusammengebaut haben zu größeren die dann irgendwann
die ersten Protoplaneten gebildet haben und das war wahrscheinlich ein großes Billard Spiel war einfach der einer den anderen.
Entweder komplett zerstört hat auch wieder beim Zusammenprall oder wenn der Zusammenprall,
Ungleichmäßigkeit weiter einer deutlich kleiner Walzer andere da ist dann was da geblieben und nachdem was für heute was viele.
Mg Wissenschaftler heute glauben ist jetzt auf der Mond bei so einer Kollision entstanden ist wobei es auch nach wie vor der ungeklärte Fragen gibt.
Vielleicht weil ich das vorhin auch noch nicht völlig.
Zufriedenstellend erklärt habe so wie kommt man auf diesen Zeitstempel des Alters der Erde.
Was man sich angucken kann und man sucht sich in sehr altes Gestein,
also z.b. aus dem Präkambrium also dieser diesen diesen ersten paar hundert und Milliarden Jahren der Erdgeschichte und sucht darin bestimmte Minerale.
Die man radiometrisch datiert also man sucht sich da ein ein Mineral das hat ein bestimmtes YouTube drin was eine gute hat wer Zeit hat und diese langen Zeiträume sich anzugucken z.b. dieses Uran-238 und.
Man muss natürlich sicherstellen dass dieses Mineral wo dieses also Festgestein quasi ein ein Mineralkörnchen dass das stabil geblieben ist über die Zeit der Erdgeschichte so dass da nicht irgendwie mir Elementen Austausch gegeben hat und da gibt es eins das ist so ein.
Sehr weit verbreitetes weil sehr praktisches mineralis der Zug ohne Zirkon.
Erzminerale die Eigenschaft das ist sehr hart ist und,
sehr hohen Schmelzpunkt hat das heißt auch wenn es irgendwie in vulkanischen Prozessen hier aufgeschmolzen wieder fest geworden,
tektonisch zusammengepresst was weiß ich bleibt eigentlich übten in der 4b Ding unter sehr vielen natürlich vorkommende Bedingungen planetarer Prozesse stabil
und wenn man zu Kronen in so alten Gesteinen sich anguckt hat man auf der Erde gemacht.
Ich habe mal aus Zirkon.
Zirkon.
Z-cron.
Das hat mir auch mit dem Mond Sterne gemacht was die Apollo-Astronauten mitgebracht haben.
Dieser dieser Zirkon wenn da Altersangaben rauskommen die,
in die richtige Richtung gehen ja dann guckt man sich in der Verteilung an sind die ältesten zu Kronen im Gestein dann hat man gutes guten guten Richtwert.
Und daher kommen dieser diese Zeitangaben auch die bei der Erde Entstehung bei viereinhalb Milliarden Jahre ungefähr liegen und beim Alter des Mondes.
Habe ich heute noch einen Artikel gesehen jetzt der jetzt ganz kürzlich erschienen ist man geht davon aus dass der Mond so zwischen 60 und 200 Millionen Jahre nach der Entstehung der Erde entstanden ist also.
Ziemlich schnell also.
Der hohe Wert 200 der ist sehr große und der neueste Wert ist er 60 also es geht tendenziell von den wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen er dahin dass man versteht der Mond ist ziemlich früh auch eigentlich entstanden.
Also die gängigen neue Definition von Planeten ist ja im Wesentlichen
Himmelskörper die heiße Sonne umkreisen und ihre Bahn freigeräumt haben also das ist sozusagen der Vorgang der im in dieser Phase dieser,
Ausbildung von erst kleinste Planet in Star Planetesimalen also zahlen die ganze Materie die ganze,
Position dieser Scheibe findet klumpig in irgendeiner Form zusammen und dann ist es so ein bisschen survival of the fittest wer kann jetzt hier irgendwie am meisten zusammen,
ziehen und irgendwann war da etwas was so eine Art brutto Erde war aber offenbar nicht ganz alleine in seiner Bahn und dann kamst du da Kollision und dann wurde eben
der Mond,
herausgeschleudert oder weiß nicht wie fern das dann total noch Teil dessen war Wasser sozusagen eingeschlagen ist schwer zu sein.
Modell Erde sind sich aber relativ ähnlich.
Das ist tatsächlich ein großes Problem dieser Theorien da dieses Einschlags eines Maß großen Planeten auf der Erde ja was er diese langläufige bis heute,
beste am besten passende Theorie ist aber dann muss man trotzdem die Frage stellen was eigentlich mit dem Material von diesem Maß großen Planeten passiert ist und.
Dessen Basis müsste man eigentlich schon Unterschiede in der Signatur bestimmter,
Isotope verschiedene Elemente auf dem Mond und auf der Erde finden also.
Warum bist du Mann dass ich meine wenn die beide zeigen aus der aus demselben bringen heraus sich gebildet haben aber nur an unterschiedlichen Stellen in der Bahn waren und dann zusammen treffen dann können Sie sich doch auch sehr ähnlich gewesen sein oder nicht das so unwahrscheinlich.
Also von den Modellen her die man sich anguckt.
Müsste es wohl Unterschiede geben also dass ich bin bisschen überfragt ich vermute es hängt,
damit zusammen wie so ein Aufschlag passiert es gibt ja auch dann bestimmte Rahmenbedingungen
wo die Erde zerstört worden wäre also das man kann schon ungefähr ausrechnen wie auch die Einschlagwinkel ist also er war wahrscheinlich völlig frontal sondern so leicht
geneigt und dann kann man ab ausrechnen wie viel Material aus der Erdkruste aus dem Erdmantel oder sogar zum Erdkern nach draußen geschleudert wurde
kann diese Verhältnisse berechnen die dann auch im späteren Mond hängengeblieben sind diese neuere Studie klappt die war vom letzten Jahr.
Hat sich auch verschiedene,
Prozess noch mal angeguckt und einen einen weiterer eine weitere Möglichkeit wie der Mond entstanden sein könnte ist dass es in einem bestimmten Zeitraum von paar Millionen Jahren filegro
kleinere Einschläge auf der Erde gegeben hat jemand auch sehr groß waren aber jetzt kein ganzer Planet der da rein gerauscht ist mit der Zeit immer wieder was hoch geht in den Orbit sozusagen transportiert wurde und.
Passt wohl auch ziemlich gut zu den wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen die man vom Mond zurück gebracht hat.
Aber da ist das letzte Wort noch nicht gesprochen also ich glaube das sächlich,
deberti die erkennt dass jemand vom Mond hat von den Apollo-Missionen die haben die haben einen Problem.
Vielleicht können wir dann kurz drüber reden also Mondlandung.
Ja Fanta Stadt.
Katja Stadt der habe ich auch gehört.
Aber schon ne Weile her.
Ist schon eine Weile her genau als die Apollo Missionen haben wir alle nur weiß auf der Erde zugewandten Seite stattgefunden höher der Mond hatte diese gebundene Rotation meistens immer nur sein Mondgesicht zu mit den schönen Maren und diese.
Deutlich mehr Mare armorama also wieder gab's auf der Mondrückseite gibt weniger Vulkanismus und deswegen sieht man viel mehr Kater und weniger diese großen Mondgesicht.
Typischen Maße von vulkanischen vulkanischer Lava wieder ausgeschlossen ist.
Also wir haben zu sagen ja nur die Vorderseite angeguckt dann sind die Apollo Missionen aus Mission.
Ja sicherheitstechnischen Gründen oder Orbit mechanischen Gründen überwiegend in der.
Noten gemacht worden.
Ja von Piloten gemacht worden aber sind vor allem auch in der Äquator Region gelandet habe wo man immer die Sonne verdreckt von oben hat Kommunikation mit der Erde,
du gehst einfach essen aber wir auch nicht hinter einer Bergkette landen und dann hat man keinen direkten Kontakt mehr und.
Das heißt das Gebiet auf dem Mond was man sich angeschaut hat mit.
Von wo Astronauten Proben genommen haben ist hat eine gewisse geologische Einschränkung.
Und wenn wir uns jetzt also gerade was also.
Der Mond ist sozusagen der Sprung der geologischen Sichtweite ins Sonnensystem in dieser Zeit die wir auf der der gar nicht haben oder ganz ganz selten irgendwo.
Outback in Australien finden aber es ist fast nicht mehr vorhanden dieses Material aus diesen ersten drei dreieinhalb Milliarden Jahren da der Mond ist in dieser Zeit gestaltet worden ist
mache ich damals auch schon geahnt weil er so viele wahnsinnig viele Krater und sich überlagernde gerade auf dem Mond gibt man gesagt hat dass es muss alles ziemlich alt sein weil
sagt über die Zeit hat man bestimmte Verteilung alle Meteoriteneinschläge.
Das ist das muss ziemlich altes Gestein sein so deswegen war das spannend jetzt dieses Material sich anzuschauen was vom Mond zurück gemacht ist weil man sozusagen diese.
Ja man kann wieder so einen absoluten alter Stempel auf dem Mund machen soll.
Nicht nur so alt dass das Ding als Ganzes sondern auch was gab es eigentlich so in der mondgeschichte für Prozesse der gab es.
Neuer Barcode.
Neue Barcode genau dieser neue Barcode musste auch erst entwickelt worden als er ganz erste Studien oder bischöfliche Beschreibung dieser Methode wie man planetare Oberflächen außerhalb der Erde.
Datiert also relativ zueinander datiert also die Oberfläche eines Himmelskörpers quasi an verschiedenen Stellen auf der Basis der Einschlagkrater also diese,
Krater Datierung der Oberfläche herum einfach sagt war mal vulkanische Ebene,
vor 2 Milliarden Jahren und dann seitdem irgendwie Meteoriten rein gehagelt na und manch waren größer mal gab es kleinere und wenn man weiß wieso die Verteilung der Meteoriteneinschläge über die Zeit waren kann man sagen da gibt's viele Krater da muss wenig gerade,
oder wo viele gerade sind das alt da wo wir nicht gerade das ist jung und kann man doch gucken welcher gerade welchen überlappt dann kann man auch sagen,
wie die im Alter zueinander sind diese lustigerweise diese Grad erzählungs und datierungsmethode,
hat ein junger Doktorand aus Deutschland,
bei der NASA gemacht oder in sich ausgedacht mit entwickelt sich ein paar Kollegen aber der ist da an erster Stelle gewesen,
und der hatte so ein bisschen so ein alfred-wegener install so nicht ganz weil der war schon Geologe und weil dieser Community drinnen aber es haben sehr viele Grad us,
Geologen die auch mit dem Apollo Material gearbeitet haben es gesagt das kann nicht funktionieren was er sich ausgedacht hat es war Gerhard Neukum.
Und.
Neukom hat es aber geschafft hat auch mit diesen radiometrischen Zeit Stempeln vom von dem Material was die Apollo-Astronauten zurückgebracht haben.
Ja in einer Relation herzustellen zum zum Alter und dann konnte man sozusagen sagen die Geschichte des Mondes ist so ein bisschen das Gegenstück,
zur Erdgeschichte also wenn man sich anguckt hier auf der Erde ist wahnsinnig viel passiert so gerade was zu uns leben angeht und willst du die alle umgestaltet hatte letzten der letzten halben Milliarde Jahre auf dem Mond war es genau umgekehrt hat ist in den ersten 12 Milliarden Jahren,
recht viel runtergekommen und.
Was jetzt auch an und für sich natürlich nicht überraschend ist wenn man sich überlegt dass diesen.
Protoplanetare Scheibe davon wann er immer noch Rest da irgendwie Asteroiden Kometen wiederum geflogen sind da ist natürlich für eingeschlagen und später wurde es mit der Zeit immer weniger,
und am Anfang war der Mond hatte ich auch heißer als heißt Cup auf mehr Vulkanismus das alles ist und dann in den ersten
genau 12 Milliarden Jahren gewesen und danach war ich nicht mehr viel an aktiven Prozessen außer dass ab und zu mal noch an Meteoriten gekommen ist.
Und mein Teil tatsächlich die Geschichte des Mondes auch nach großen Einschlagkrater nein also es gibt die.
Brennet arische reparaturpreise das ist die Epoche vor dem großen vor das große
materia medica Wäsche Becken entstanden ist dann gibt's die Imrich im Pocher wo das Mare imbrium entstanden ist also auch ein ist eines der größten Einschlag Steckbecken auf dem Mond und dann gibt's noch ein paar kleinere,
Anschläge die später passiert sind.
Und die Geologen damals dachten gerade drei Apollo-Missionen nehme ich 15 16 und 17 sind die drei letzten apollo-mission die haben Gesteine mitgebracht von.
Drei großen ein schlagbecken das war damals der Glaube also imbrium dieses ganz große Nektarien Nektarios.
Und dann noch ein drittes das ist das serenitatis ein schlagbecken also von diesem drei Becken und.
Dann müsste man jetzt denken das sind wahrscheinlich ja so grob schon drei Epochen gewesen aber tatsächlich sind diese drei schlagbecken wahnsinnig zeitlich wahnsinnig nah beieinander also.
Genau genommen weiß man noch als ich noch gar nichts weil meine Zusagen eigentlich nur an einem einzigen Ort war oder im Wesentlichen einem einzigen Bereich auf dem Montag mehr noch
gar nicht genug Daten um irgendwie jetzt finalen Schluss zu ziehen wie es um den Mond bestellt.
Jan also man hat eigentlich schon diese diese apollo-mission obwohl man dieser Quad oder Region Gruppe lassen musste gedacht man hätte drei verschiedene Orte angeflogen hat aber festgestellt dass das Gestein dieser Sorte,
fast komplett gleich altes nämlich bei dreieinhalb 3,9 also grob vier Milliarden Jahren entstanden ist,
und daraus ist eine concept entstanden was bis heute auch einigermaßen zu Lidl müssen umstritten ist nämlich dass es ein spätes großes Bombardement gegeben hat LED heavy bombardment.
Das ist eigentlich hat man gedacht ursprünglich scapare am Anfang viele Einschläge und dann so ein exponentiellen ab.
Up up up zum Abschminken mit der Zeit aber tatsächlich gab es mal viele Einschläge langsam anfangen es wurde immer weniger und da gibt's noch mal so ein Speikind plötzlich wo es noch mal mehr das war dir das bei per4me an Jahren und dann wird es weniger.
Und interessant ist das z.b. wenn man sich überlegt dass die ersten Fossilien die man auf der Erde findet kurze Zeit danach abgelagert worden also wenn der Mond manchmal ziemlich heftig durchgerüttelt wurde,
und wir sprechen hier von Einschlägen da sind 20 km große Meteoriten also Asteroiden auf dem Mond gestürzt also auf der Erde ist das dann auch schon.
Totalschaden wahrscheinlich sogar dass das Leben als Ganzes möglicherweise verschwunden ist.
Und ich meine wenn der Mond bombardiert wurde es ist relativ wahrscheinlich das ist auch die Erde getroffen hat.
Genau genau ja und tatsächlich hat man,
ehrliche Verläufe zeitliche Verläufe, da diese Zeitstempel nicht hat ne aber relativ zueinander hat sie war auf dem Mars sieht man auf der Venus nicht weil da gibt's zu viel Vulkanismus aber auch auf dem Merkur kann man den beobachten.
Also alle inneren fest Gesteinsplaneten sind wahrscheinlich in der Zeit massiv bombardiert worden.
Bitte ist ja auch noch mal etwas weiter in der Stille erwähnenswert ist es der Mond ist sozusagen so ein komplettes.
Historisches Abbild seiner See,
also der Mangel an Tektonik und dadurch dass ich das sagen nicht so ein heißes Magma was die ganze Zeit von radioaktiven Zerfall in Bewegung gehalten wird,
nicht die ganze Zeit aufbläht und alles durcheinander cheaten immer wieder neu mischt macht das sozusagen so einen permanenten Speicher der seiner ganzen Geschichte was halt in der Erde so nicht der Fall ist.
Positiv war immer erst mal fragen warum ist denn das eigentlich so heftet da kein radioaktiver Zerfall Stadt und wenn der Mond ehrlich genauso ist wie die Erde warum finden da nicht dieselben Prozesse statt.
Das ist eine Frage der Größe tatsächlich also die Größe einen planetarer Körper ist umso länger kann er seine.
Wärme auf Speichern das ist eine Sache das Verhältnis von Oberfläche zu Volumen also mit dem Volumen.
Aber zu klein.
Ist einfach zu kleinen verlierst du es zu schlecht isoliert letzlich nach außen ja.
Verstehe.
Also auf der Maas hat ja wahrscheinlich einen inneren flüssigen Kern aber er hat keinen planetares Magnetfeld wie die Erde also keinen keinen kein Dipol Magnetfeld,
und die der Sonderfall bei der Erde ist ja das ist an diesem festen inneren und den,
flüssigen äußeren Kern gibt und das ist einfach dass ich sowas halten kann über die Zeit ist eine Frage der Größe des planetaren Körpers nützlich,
aber der relevante. Ist genau.
Zum Papa wieder munter sein ich für Geologen total spannend weil man sehr weit in die Geschichte zurück gucken kann und sich da einfach nichts in einer Zeit zurück bewegen kann die auf der Erde überhaupt nicht mehr,
abgebildet ist ein Gestein bzw sie ist vielleicht irgendwie in irgendwelchen alten großen Stücken ab,
gebildet die längst auf den einmal durch den Erdmantel abgetaucht sind und irgendwo Richtung Erdkern dümpeln gerade einmal durch die Erde durch aber es ist für uns kaum noch verfügbar.
Käme doch mal wieder auf die.
Erde zurück und schaue noch mal was sich jetzt sozusagen aus dem ganzen wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen der letzten Zeit,
herausgebildet hat also was kann man denn jetzt,
sicher sagen welche Skala müssen wir jetzt hier aufhalten wenn wir die Erde betrachten und was sind vorallem so die großen nennenswerten,
Änderungen gewesen die man vielleicht mal auf den Zeiger haben sollte weil jetzt durch jedes einzelne Erdzeitalter durch zu poltern ist sicherlich ein bisschen müßig erstmal gibt's dir viel zu viele und die Änderung der Änderungen sind natürlich dann,
vielleicht wissenschaftlich relevant aber jetzt nicht unbedingt immer so groundbreaking.
Ja
Gerade wenn man jetzt sagt die Erde ist 4,3 Milliarden Jahre alt.
4,45 ungefähr.
Oder 4,45 Zoll,
selfie so dass es so ein Geburtstag gab wodota da jetzt geht's los ja sondern das war ja selber ein Prozess der irgendwie lange gedauert hat so also fing der vor 4,45 Milliarden Jahren,
Anna sollen sich da die ersten Steinchen zusammengefunden
vermutlich nicht sagen wir sprechen ja von irgendeinem irgendeinem Schwellenwert der sozusagen erreicht wurde also irgendwann war es groß genug und alleine genug um in irgendeiner Form auch messbar ein alter zu haben.
Ja also tatsächlich das habe ich auch jetzt erst kürzlich gelernt im Zuge der Vorbereitung für diese Sendung.
Wo kommt diese 4,5 Milliarden Jahre her ich habe ja vorhin die Zeolithe erwähnt
und tatsächlich hat man sich überlegt dass wenn man jetzt Zeolithe nimmt jemand auf der Erde gefunden hat die können ja da besteht schon gewisses Risiko dass die,
mit der Zeit.
Verändert worden sind ja weil die Erde einfach so wahnsinnig biologisch-dynamisch unterwegs ist und so wahnsinnig viel passiert und deswegen hat man sich bestimmte Meteorite angeguckt bei Meteorite also,
Brocken aus dem Aldi auf die Erde fallen sind irgendwie zum Teil
Überbleibsel diese Entstehungsphase und da gibt's verschiedene Klassen und man schätzt auf Basis von irgendwelchen chemischen Erkenntnissen halt dass bestimmte Klassen von Meteoriten besonders gut geeignet sind so und dieses,
urtümlicher Material abzubilden und da drin hat man die Zeolithe gesucht und das Alter der Erde quasi oder der,
der inneren Planeten also das bezieht sich dann nicht mehr auf die Erde sondern alle inneren Planeten haben diesen Europiden Zeitstempel.
Und dann hat man als zweiten Schritt angeguckt wo finde ich alte Gesteine auf der Erde wo ich auch diese Zeolithe drin habe und guckt was ist mit ihm zusammen was in diesem primitiven,
Meteoriten zu finden ist und das passte gut zusammen ja das ist also dadurch relativ gut abgesichert.
Also was genaues abgesichert also da.
Ja dieser Zeitstempel also das alt.
Sehr gut aber in welchem Zustand befand sich die Erde also sie hat sozusagen ihre ihre Masse gehabt die sie jetzt hat so also war vollständig war hat alles eingesammelt die Bahn war freigeräumt.
Die Bahn war weitgehend freigeräumt das Ding war wahrscheinlich erstmal noch recht heiß weil viel vulkanische M44 radioaktiver Zerfall ja weil die das hatte gerade erst alles angefangen zu zerfallen und,
hinzu kam das natürlich auch die ganzen Zusammenstöße die zum Planeten Wildung geführt haben viel Wärme Energie freigesetzt haben,
falls es gab auf allen Gesteinsplaneten inklusive der Erde dieser Magma Ozean Phase vor die Oberfläche so heiß war,
einige 1000° 5000 Grad oder so also das ist so heiß wie heute die Oberfläche der Sonne ist so heiß war die planetaren Oberflächen damals dass du da war sozusagen keine feste Struktur so fängts an also das war das,
der Reset und bei im Zuge der Abkühlung hat man jetzt so magmatische Prozesse dass bestimmte Minerale sich bilden,
die Schmelztemperatur für Zeolith glaube ich wenn es richtig im Kopf hat bei 1800 Grad also das sind da gibt's dann bestimmte,
Minerale die sehr früh entstehen also sobald noch bei noch recht hohen vergleichsweise hohen Temperaturen und wenn man sich deswegen guckt man sich die an weil die einfach früh da raus gefallen sind
und es gibt heute auch kaum magmatische Prozesse die Temperaturen auf Malta.
Das heißt solange die Erde so heiß war hätten sozusagen diese Mineralien gar nicht überleben können.
Die werden sozusagen.
Das heißt in dem Moment wo man so ein Mineral datiert auf dieses Alter weiß man auch hier zu dem Zeitpunkt war die Erde zumindest schon mal so kalt.
Pascal kreativ 1800 gratis ist kein Zuckerschlecken aber man kann sozusagen auch schon von einer gewissen Abkühlung und damit auch einer Stabilisierung der Erde sprechen.
Genau dass das Fachgebiet der Therme Chronologie und man kann mit diesem nicht die Truppen Verhältnissen auch Temperaturen entstehungs Temperaturen von festen Gesteinen und Mineralien durchführen.
Okay also wir haben so ein so ein so ein so ein so einen immer noch ziemlich überhitzten Gesteinsblock der ja nicht jetzt komplett flüssig ist aber zumindest wie schwer an sich arbeitet so muss man sich das vorstellen.
Genau genau jetzt geht's los naja die Erde ist irgendwie fest und.
Reicht irgendwann den Temperaturbereich wo dann auch.
Aus was ist organische Prozesse erzeugen immer Gase also,
Wasserdampf CO2 Gas z.b. und dieser Zeit gab es viele Ausgasungen und dann gab es aber halt.
Diese fest feste erstarrte Oberfläche nach Uratmosphäre und dann gab es irgendwann diese späte Bombardement.
Ja wo die Erde wo der Mond verunstaltet wurde und wahrscheinlich auf dem Erde komplett sterilisiert und wo auch wahrscheinlich noch mal große Teile der.
Erdoberfläche noch mal ein zweites Mal aufgeschmolzen worden sind.
Genau diese Uhr Erde hat übrigens Gase eingesammelt also diese urwolke bestand ja auch z.b. aus Wasserstoffgas also es gab auch einen Ort musst Fehler der Erde die dann wieder verloren war.
Und deswegen glaub mal nicht dass die Atmosphäre.
Die Uratmosphäre die dann entstand aus dir die dann später das entstehende Leben genutzt hat und dann immer noch umgebaut hat z.b. zu mehr Sauerstoff dass dies später dazu bekam ist wirklich so kleineren,
Meteoriteneinschläge durch Kometen da wird ja auch immer noch diskutiert ob ich mehr Asteroiden oder mehr Kometen waren.
Zurzeit klappt mal Erismann mirista Druiden.
Interessant ist also wenn man mehr als Wissenschaft Bildwissenschaft geschichtlich weiterschauen also man hat ja Z-95 den ersten dass er Sex Planetensystem entdeckt versr wirklich die ersten,
Planeten außerhalb unseres Sonnensystems und bis dann hat man echt geglaubt dass so was bei uns passiert ist,
wahrscheinlich der Durchschnitt war da also was was sollte man anderes tun also wir kennen nur das was wir kennen und.
Also das man irgendwie Planetensysteme hat aus und wir Gasriesen tin haben wir ja kleine Planeten und.
Was wir bis heute wissen es ja eher das Gegenteil also unser Sonnensystem ist irgendwie.
Außergewöhnlich weil unsere Gasriesen sind voll weit draußen und es gibt sehr viele Planetensysteme mit Pferdehaaren Gasriesen
was ein bisschen mit dem Beobachtungsmethoden zusammenhängt weil wir können ja einfach leichter beobachten wenn sie kurz Umlaufzeiten haben und dafür müssen seine am Stern sein dass
kann sich noch verschieben und Bekleidung stand daneben kann man fängt ja gerade erst an das man die zunehmend auch,
Wachtel kann anders vor aber was im Gang gesetzt wurde durch diese Entdeckungen war,
dass ich Theoretiker jetzt Entwicklung von Planetensystem angeschaut haben überlegt haben wie kann über die Zeit so ein Planetensysteme nennt sich entwickeln und wie können wir dabei auch Tochter Serge,
wir schreiben was wir bei uns beobachtet haben z.b. diese späte Bombardement plötzlich noch mal viel mehr Meteoriten kommen und wo kommt das her.
Da gibt's einen einer Arbeitsgruppe die das gestartet hat 2005.
Eine Gruppe um einen italienischen theoretischen Astrophysiker Alessandro Morbidelli und der hat ein Rechenmodell quasi also muss eigentlich Form theoretische Physik erstmal,
der hat sich einfach angeguckt wie wie was muss im Planetensystem passiert sein was könnte im Planetensystem passiert sein dass es noch mal so viele Meteoriten gegeben hat,
die dann den Mund verunstaltet haben und die Erde und dieses Nizza Modell heißt es als erstes,
Observatorium der Cote d'Azur Nizza quasi entwickelt Miesmuschel das.
War bis vor paar Jahren waren paar Jahre hat paar Jahre lang hat sozusagen sah so aus als könnte man das jetzt erklären warum es dieses bombat morgen gegeben hat und.
Das ist letztlich so eine Art spätes späte Form des Planeten Billard.
Die sich noch mal eignet hatten alles klappt dieses anfangs bejaht dann war lange Stillstand irgendwie war mein Bier trinken und dann ging das Billard Spiel noch mal kurz weiter weil die.
Orbitz der Planeten der der wasserreichsten Planeten Jupiter und Saturn Hamm.
Eine Resonanz entwickelt irgendwann also die hatten schon fast ihre heutigen Bahn sind aber noch ein bisschen näher an die Sonne gewartet mit der Zeit und dann.
Hatte das war aufgeschaukelt.
Hat hat sich was aufgeschaukelt dass es gab sozusagen eine Resonanz das heißt ein ganzzahliges Verhältnis von den Umlauf Perioden dieser beiden planiert.
Bei Resonanz wieder.
Dadurch hat sich das verstärkt.
Und das führt dazu dass plötzlich bestimmte Umlaufbahn im Sonnensystem instabil werden erweist er plötzlich Kräfte wirken die vorher da nicht waren und.
Dieses Nizza Modell ging er davon aus dass es ein sehr sehr breiten Asteroidengürtel damals.
Vor dieser Resonanz gegeben hat sie mir heute nicht mehr sehen und der dadurch sozusagen in alle Winde,
davon geschossen wurde und wahrscheinlich sogar das was wir heute Käufer Gürtel nennen also diese Zone hinter der Neptunbahn wo ist der Pluto dazu gehört aber auch noch vier weitere ausreicht dass der in der Zeit quasi mit entstanden ist.
Weil diese Resonanz quasi das Zeug verteilt hat und es hatte halt diese Körper wahrscheinlich nicht nur ins äußere sondern auch ins Innere System gelegt.
Was am Anfang war nur Staub dann hat sich alles erstmal soweit zurecht gefunden das eben diese großen Planetensysteme sich haben herausbilden können dann liefen die so eine Weile aber irgendwann gab es dann mal so ein,
weil die eben sich alle sozusagen so gut eingelaufen haben durch diese Resonanz durch diese Verstärkung irgendwie so einen Effekt,
irgendeins dieser Objekte aus dem normalen Lauf der Dinge herausgehen und dann gabs
kollisionskasko Aden quasi oder diese ganzen,
aber dieser Breite Asteroidengürtel vor allem wurde rausgeschnitten ist auch heute noch so dass diese Asteroidengürtel vor allem deshalb
keinem keinen weiteren Planeten ausbilden würde ja meinen ja wenn er jetzt so viele kleine Dinge sind warum ziehen die sich nicht an und schließen sich auch noch mal zu einem neuen Planeten zusammen das wird verhindert dadurch dass der Jupiter das sozusagen
immer wieder aus der aus dem Gleichgewicht bringt und sozusagen immer wieder neu zerstoeren oder,
weiß ich gleich gar nicht erst soweit kommen lässt dass ich da was finden kann habe ich aber reich war viel größer und irgendwann mal sozusagen ja die Billardkugel für das einen schönen,
vergleiche alles fliegt einmal in alle Richtungen und dann Klimbim und da könnte dann auch die Erde was abbekommen haben.
Genau also das könnte für die Erde auch so ein eigenes gewesen sein die wo wo noch mal alles auf Null gesetzt wurde was.
Aber das war ja noch relativ früh zu dem Zeitpunkt war das Ding vielleicht schon bisschen abgekühlt aber nicht von dem was wir heute sozusagen sehen und spüren war schon entwickelt ein sehr früher Zeit.
Ja für die Erde,
kann man das so sehen also die Frage ist da gibt's auch Hunde von Sophos lilienartige Strukturen oder denkt auch durch chemische Biomarkern also übersetze nicht unbedingt Fossilien sind in dem Sinne und sagt er war irgendwie dieses
wann müssen bestimmte kohlenstoffisotope angereichert in diesem Gestein der spricht doch schon dafür dass da was auf Graphites und Bene besteht er aus aus.
Kohlenstoff und da gibt's bestimmt der isotopische,
Signatur Nummer sagen hat das ist vielleicht auch durchleben entstanden aber dann bewegen wir uns in den Bereich also da sind wir unter Umständen schon vor diesem großen Bombardement aber da streiten die Geologen auch ob der wirklich Leben eine Rolle gespielt hat.
Interessant ist was anderes nämlich also wenn wir uns die Maße angucken die Geschichte des Mars.
Der Maß ist ja ähnlich wie der Mond hat also er hat irgendwie schon eine durchgängige geologische Geschichte weiß mehr als,
Allert hat auf dem Mond eine Atmosphäre gibt und auch heute noch biologisch aktive Prozesse die natürlich auf dem anderen Maßstab Abläufen ist auf der Erde es gibt keine Plattentektonik auf dem Mars aber es gibt.
Ja Staub Transport es gibt wahrscheinlich bis heute auch bekanntes muss auf dem Maß wenn der auch früher viel stärker gewesen ist.
Aber man geht ja davon aus auf der Basis der ganzen Marssonden das flüssiges Wasser und vielleicht auch eine dichte möglicherweise eine dichte Atmosphäre in dieser frühen Phase auch
stattgefunden hatten also die die die dynamischen biologischen Prozesse waren ja auch vier bis bis.
Zu einer Zeit vor dreieinhalb Milliarden Jahren auf dem Mars aktiv ja und das ist ja gerade warum suchen wir so
besessen nach Spuren von Leben auf dem Mars wir wollen gerade in diese Zeit vordringen also man fährt in diese Gesteine curiosity ist jetzt gerade in dem Bereich wo auch Sonne,
gell Krater wo auch seine geologische Schichtgrenze wahrscheinlich existiert wo.
Also Kiraz der der Ro.
Der NASA Mars Rover genau der der neueste der 2012 gelandet ist der auch diese Chemielaborant Wort hat aus diesem Grund hermanville und wie verstehen wie die ablagerungs Bedingung waren.
Und.
Ja also es gibt Ideen dass dieses nördlicher Flachland des Maßmann von Ozean bedeckt worden ist und die Zeit wo man noch.
Nach Allmersbach heute weiß davon ausgeht dass der Mars am erdähnlichen gewesen ist das ist auch die Zeit von diesem großen Bombardement also kurze Zeit davor und danach.
Und das ist also durchaus eine relevante Frage.
Optimas an ausgetrieben wurde durch das Bombardement.
Das könnte sein es ist kann man heute nicht beantworten weil wir haben vom Mars keine.
Promass gibt's ein paar Meteoriten aber da weiß man nicht genau wo sie herkommen auf einmal weiß man was sie sind vom Mars aber nicht aus welchem Gestein aber wir haben ja noch keine,
Chrome Rückholung Format durchgeführt deswegen ist eine Datierung von Marsgestein auf Basis also zu unserem Zeitstempel.
Nicht möglich her wir können das einzige was wir machen können ist heute hauptsächlich auch gerade erzählen,
Oberflächendruck der Tieren da gibt es zum einen Gips große Spannbreiten von Altersangaben also der der Fehler die man jeden Messwert die man mit dieser Methode gewinnt ist ziemlich groß.
6 groß Ungenauigkeiten und dazu kommt dass diese ganze Krater,
Zählmethode Datierung planetare Oberflächen auf dem und kalibriert worden ist ja also mein Kater geht da geht da vom Mond aus und von diesen.
Gestein die bei diesen drei Apollo-Missionen Pferde gekommen sind und das wackelt alles also gerade auf Mond hat man vor ein paar Jahren festgestellt dass wahrscheinlich alle,
Apollo Mission 15 16 und 17 gar nicht drei verschiedene Einschlags Becken sich angeschaut haben sondern.
Allesamt die Auswürfe von dem größten Einschlags Becken Mare imbrium.
Und das hat das hat man festgestellt auf Basis von hochauflösenden Bildern die man halt erst vor ein paar Jahren machen konnte das heißt das heißt.
2. mal wieder hinzufahren.
Genau ja sag ihr auch viele wobei das sind irgendwie überwiegen keine Wissenschaftler aber deswegen freuen sich die Wissenschaftler darüber.
Das heißt aber auch diese Idee dass es sowas wie ein großes Bombardement gab die ist also bis in Verruf gekommen ne weil man irgendwie die Datenbasis das wahrscheinlich gar nicht hergibt.
Also das finde ich das Spannende an dem Thema,
geologische Zeit wenn wir uns im Sonnensystem bewährt bewegen ist halt alles irgendwie ist alles so der der Anker dem alles dran hängt sind diese Proben vom Mond vom Apollo Programm,
die jetzt 50 Jahre alt sind und der ist irgendwie nicht so gut fest.
Aber die Chinesen sind doch jetzt auf der Rückseite des Mondes gelandet.
Genau die die Chinesen sind aus Poetiken gelandet ist ist das größte Einschlags Becken des Sonnensystems.
Und es ist schon mal dort wo man auf jeden Fall hin will wenn man diese
geologische Alter Skala genauer untersuchen will also ich glaube der Youtuber zwei dieser ja da hatte zwei der ist nicht ausgestattet jetzt da Alters Messung zu machen aber die nächste chinesische,
Lande Sonde chunky 5 die noch jetzt 2019 ja starten soll gucken ob das mit der neuen schwerlastrakete da jetzt gut klappt die soll ja bis zu zwei Kilo,
unterstand Pferde zurück,
das erste Mal seit die Sowjets das mit Luna gemacht haben ich glaube 76 und das wird das erste Mal sein dass man recht junges Gestein vom Mond zurückhält holt das heißt man hat jetzt.
Die die Abholung Messdaten sind alle recht aus recht alten Zeiten und da gibt es in Orth auf der Mond Vorderseite Gutschein G5 landen soll.
Und da guck mal in die jüngere mondgeschichte rein und da hat man dann sozusagen schon mal einen Messwert auf der anderen Seite der geologischen Geschichte des Mondes also das wird wird sicher helfen.
So was waren denn so die nächsten relevanten Ereignisse für unsere.
Sich abkühlende und von zusätzlichen Asteroiden Bewurf leidende Erde.
Wo müssen wir den nächsten Marker setzen was ist das nächste grundlegende Ändern der Ereignis was die Erde an das heran geführt hat was wir heute kennen.
Also ich würde sagen das war überwiegend,
intern bedingt na also wir haben bei spätestens bei so dreieinhalb 3,4 Milliarden Jahren diese ersten Mikroorganismen und sie sich immer weiter austarieren der leben dann gab es diese,
schon erwähnte den schon erwähnten Umbau der Atmosphäre wahrscheinlich erst zu Methan reichen Atmosphäre und später da Sauerstoff Atmosphäre.
Lustig oder interessant in dem Zusammenhang vielleicht noch,
am Anfang warst du CO2 Atmosphäre also 100 fast 100% CO2 wie viel heute auf dem Mars sehen.
Aber da richtig da das heißt es gab auch einen recht starken Treibhauseffekt durch sich CO2 so und dann hat das Leben halt angefangen über Fotosynthese also die ersten.
Cyanobakterien als historische einfache Einzeller die schon Fotosynthese treiben konnten.
Nicht nur Sauerstoff zu erzeugen sondern in dem Zug auch dass dir zuerst Atmosphäre zu filtern das heißt dem Treibhauseffekt der abzumildern dadurch.
Das Treibhausgas verschwand und in der Zeit,
der kälter geworden und im Zusammenhang damit anderen auch teilweise externen Faktoren wie ich schätze mal Sonnenaktivität Schwankung von erdbahnparameter was er bis heute auch die,
z.b. die Eiszeiten triggert ist die Erde all teilweise auch beinahe komplett zugefroren noch mal.
Aber wann war denn überhaupt der Zeitpunkt gekommen wo sie mal kalt war also kalt im Sinne von das flüssiges Wasser außen
überhaupt so stattfinden könnte weil zuletzt waren noch bei 1800 Grad das der ist nicht so ganz die optimale Badetemperatur
der dieser totale Übersetzungsprozess muss ja dann auch irgendwann mal so ein Punkt gefunden haben wo ist Ozeane überhaupt erst
möglichst waren weil das muss ja dann Prinzip die ganze Zeit ein Irrer Kochtopf gewesen sein die Erde.
Also die ersten paar hundert Millionen Jahre war die Erde und durch heiß und auch wo ist dann unter 100 Grad die Durchschnittstemperatur der Oberfläche gesunken ist und dann vielleicht auch schon Niederschläge gab weiß ich ja Dampfkochtopf erstmal.
Aber letztlich liegt die Kondensation der Ozeane rechten Arm von vom Alter der der ersten Fossilien also.
Verblüffend nahe würde ich fast sagen weil ich denk mal die Entstehung des Lebens an sich ist ein Thema für sich ja was ich jetzt hier nicht aufmachen will aber,
ist Weiher es ist ja sozusagen dass das Hauptproblem diesen diese Lebensentstehung zu erklären ist so diese Komplexität.
Biologischen album von von von Zellmetabolismus letztlich wer sowie die und und der Genomik und was alles rein spielt wie wie die entstehen kann.
Wie du überhaupt entstehen kann und so wie es aussieht passierte das ziemlich direkt nachdem die Temperatur hingehauen hat also.
Du hast in dem Moment wo quasi die Temperatur so niedrig war und damit Ozean überhaupt erst möglich waren weil nicht alles kochte,
Atalay waschen vermutlich diese pure Anwesenheit dieser Wassermassen einfach relativ schnell dazu geführt dass dieser Prozess in,
in Wallung gehen weil einfach kosmische Strahlung quasi das Mutation Zwerg angerichtet hat und der Rest war dann einfach ja Konsequenz aus allem.
Das wäre eine mögliche Erklärung Nase wir haben keine gesicherten Erkenntnisse wir hatten kochen irgendwie unsere miller-urey-experiment Süppchen seit 70 Jahren améliorée handelt in den 50er Jahren ja angefangen irgendwie,
da gibt's glaube ich wahrscheinlich wirds nihil zufriedenstellende erkennt dass sie darüber geben,
ein Erklärungsansatz der das Problem nicht löst aber verschiebt wäre zu sagen naja vielleicht,
kamen die ersten Spuren des Lebens auch von woanders diese panspermie.
Also dieser dieser Gedanke ist natürlich genauso müßig letzlich aber ich finde ihn deshalb witzig weil ja auf der Erde immer wieder auf große Einschläge stattgefunden haben und da gab's also eine Studie die hatte ich gesehen.
Da ging es um den Einschlag dabei Mexiko den chicxulub-krater die hat das Ende der Dinosaurier.
Amtlich besiegelt oder zumindest stark beeinflusst hat,
und da gab es eine Eruptionswolke sag mir das ausrechnet dass wenn dieser physischer Körper da eingeschlagen ist die die Erdbahn verlassen hat also das Material der Erde,
ins Sonnensystem geschleudert worden und dann kann man einfach mit statistischen Modell sich ausrechnen wie viel Brocken von der Erde,
die größer als 3 Meter sind das ist so eine Zahl damit kommt man auch durch die Atmosphären die überall im Sonnensystem sind gut durch,
und so dass mich alles auf mit,
und da sind irgendwie 26 Millionen solcher Brocke broken auf die Venus gestürzte von tim ein Einschlag auf der Erde.
Fast 1 Million auf dem Merkur 300.000 auf dem Mars 6 auf dem Jupitermond Europa ja der irgendwie,
ja sechs broken 3M aber ich meine wenn er dem Papi Chromgrill lieben und der aus irgendeinem Grund da irgendwie ins Eis eingearbeitet wurde von Europa der hatte diese planetare ozeanische,
also diese Planeten sagt man dieser diese Eiskruste oder der sich ein Ozean befindet und mit flüssigen Wasser.
Es kann durchaus sein das Leben der Erde andere Körper befruchtet hatte.
Okay kann kann sein was mich persönlich weniger fasziniert ist so ja gut das hätte jetzt gleich von anderen Planeten kommen können aber
warum soll denn auf der Erde nicht genau dasselbe auch so stattfinden können was bei denen auch stattfindet man die sind auch im selben Sonnensystems mehr oder weniger alles aus demselben Kram zusammen gefegt worden,
klar die flüchtige Elemente Etagen da draußen,
größer vertreten deswegen ja auch die Gasplaneten trotzalledem ist es am Ende.
Alles auch denselben Bedingungen ausgesetzt und von daher könnte ich.
Dann im Serum wissenschaftlichen anders selbstverständlich mir das auch genauso herleiten mit na ja warum soll das nicht bei uns auch statt.
Ja genau.
Oder ist irgendwas weiter draußen offensichtlich besser geeignet um Leben zu starten als bei uns.
Ich würde sagen das ist schon am plausibelsten das ist Leben bei uns entstanden ist und das passt schon ins Bild außer dass man so im Detail nicht nachvollziehen kann aber man hat ja auch nicht Millionen Jahre Zeit im Labor Süppchen zu kochen.
Was ein großes Problem ist aber ich find's bloß vom umgekehrten Fall interessanten also wenn wir irgendwann dann doch mal Spuren von Leben auf dem Mars finden oder,
innen Ausgasungen vom Saturnmond Enceladus ist es durchaus.
Schleuderte Dinosaurier sein.
Wahrscheinlich dass das alles mal von der Erde kam.
Vätternrundan kompletten Dinosaurier irgendwie auf dem Mars abgeschmissen.
Das ist möglich genau vorbei wo sind die Post die abgelagerten Raumschiffe von denen.
Muss curiosity noch ein bisschen noch ein bisschen suchen okay gut also jetzt.
Gibt's Leben setzt das jetzt mal voraus gibt Ozeane die Plattentektonik ist auch am werkeln.
Ab jetzt geht alles sozusagen seinen gewohnten Gang noch mal irgendwelche nennenswerten Änderungen.
Also.
Die Erdgeschichte ist irgendwie ja nicht völlig geradlinig also auch wenn wir uns jetzt die letzten 540 Millionen angucken wo es irgendwie dieser,
Lebewesen gab mit ihrem Knochenbau wo wir ganz gut nachverfolgen können was so passiert ist wo wir ausgestorben ist da gibt's ja Brüche drin in dieser Geschichte.
Sprüche mein positiver wie negativer Richtung also es gab sicher als einem erstmal einen,
positives Ereignis dieser kambrische radiation oder Explosion wo innerhalb kürzester Zeit wahnsinnig viele Tierarten aufgetaucht sind die.
Bled.
Das ist sicher auch ein Prozess der einfach innerhalb der Evolution und diesem Gleichgewicht was ich meinen steht zwischen Räubern und.
Jagten sagt man Beutetieren na die einen entwickeln Zähne und die anderen Panzer so und das schaukelt sich ziemlich schnell auf weil es muss irgendwie Gleichgewicht sich finden und die die mal bisschen bessere Panzer haben die,
Überlebenden und dann geht das immer so weiter aber da ist interessant ist er das wirklich,
bis vor einer halben Milliarde Jahre das Leben so vor sich hin dümpelt hat da gab's
wahnsinnig lange Zeiträume diese Einzeller und dann sind wir Erzähler da gibt's so ein paar Funde von so überlieferten quallenartige Dinger die noch keine Skelette hatten und plötzlich innerhalb von wenigen Jahrmillionen also wirklich zum,
für schnips.
Gibt's wahnsinnig viele Tiere mit Skeletten also es gibt sie. In der Entwicklung des Lebens wo plötzlich alles anders ist.
Also es gibt aber lange Zeiträume und dann plötzlich so ganz dynamische Effekte ja wo jetzt.
Erfolgsmodell einfach.
Genau her da hat sich hat die der Zufall und die Selektion zusammen irgendwie was.
Was gemacht was was ich dann durchsetzt und dann gibt es aber auch die Brüche in die andere Richtung na das sind diese großen 5,
Massenaussterben gnisse dies in der Erdgeschichte gegeben hatte der Geschichte des Lebens auf der Erde gegeben hat,
ich habe vorher noch mehr aber so in der Zeit die wir jetzt mit den mehrzellern mit mehrzelligen Leben gut überblicken können.
Und die haben mich alle bekannte Ursachen also es gibt.
Sicher die die wir kennen das letzte ganz große hatte ich gesagt dieses.
Grenze von Kreide und Tertiär wo die Dinosaurier ausgestorben sind.
Aber das war bei weitem nicht das größte Massenaussterben ist das war wahrscheinlich die Pantry US-Grenze es ist die Zeit also die Welt,
der ist schon einfache Reptilien gab und und Fische und Amphibien und Insekten.
Unterging und von den noch sympal bricht lieben und dass ein paar von diesen Überlebenden einfachen Reptilien plötzlich die Dinosaurier entstanden also das.
In der Pantry US-Grenze sind 96% wenn ich richtig im Kopf habe also ein sehr großer Teil aller Landlebewesen ausgestorben und noch größerer Teil aller Wasser lebenden Organismen.
Und geht's dir deine Theorie was dazu geführt hat.
Wahrscheinlich war es der Kombination also es gab wahrscheinlich eine Schwächung der Lebewelt weil es so ein Superkontinent gehabt und Superkontinent heißt es gibt weniger Ökosysteme na weiß weiß mehr.
Die Konsolidierung der Arten gibt sozusagen der Superkontinent befand sich in kontinentale Region also war sehr trocken in weiten Teilen und dass das Klima war sozusagen dämlich zu zuträglich,
und dann muss wahrscheinlich noch ein zusätzlicher,
m-effekt eingetreten sein der dann die Umwelt vergiftet hat eine Theorie ist über dich mal vom paar Jahren geschrieben habe das Kohleflöze in Sibirien,
sehr großer vulkanische Aktivität in dieser Region die sibirischen Trapps heißen die zusammen kamen also da wurden quasi von vulkanischen,
Lava vulkanischer Lava wieder rausgekommen ist wurden Kohleflöze angesteckt hast gaben riesengroße Kohlekraftwerke und wohnt in Sibirien.
Und dann entsprechend Verdunklung.
Saurer Regen.
Genau also saurer Regen der Verdauung der Oberfläche global also gibt auch Parallelen zu heute und ich sagen zumindest so in den Ansätzen bewegen uns auch in diese Richtung und.
Und dann bricht halt berechnet unter Nahrungsketten zusammen also ich glaube wenn so ein Prozess dann irgendwann.
Startet und die Liebe wird sowieso geschwächt ist und ich so diverses dann dann geht's auch schneller.
Diese Pantry as ist aber noch nicht so ganz geklärt und gerade was die früheren Masse ausstellbar Klassen angeht dass es gibt 1 zwischen Darm Ordovizium Silur Nase sollte ich so die ganz frühen 400.
Bring dir dann mal kurz mal in die Reihenfolge.
Ja okay es sind viele ne so Kambrium habe ich gesagt.
Du hast auf vier oder fünf hast Du erwähnt.
Okay jetzt bei wir uns jetzt die großen Einheiten angucken also.
Das Präkambrium das ist für alles was am Anfang war da gehört die SAG archeum Moment archean dazu und das Proterozoikum also da war so wie alles aus der Proto.
Und dann beginnt das Kambrium und das gehört zum und dann ist es letzte Stunde Dreiteilung es gibt das Palio zurückkommen wieso zurückkommen 10 Uhr zoikum also ert.
Altzeit Mitte Zeit und Neuzeit ja und das zoikum heißt es ist alles passiert alles auf hier.
Vorkommen oder Arten verschiedener von also nicht nur Tiere auf Pflanzen genau,
ja und zwischen diesen großen Zeitaltern gibt's massiver aussterbeereignisse die hatte ich jetzt gerade genannten also Perm Trias wo dann die Dinosaurier anfingen,
und Kreide Tertiär wurde die Dinosaurier aufhörten das definiert die Dinosaurier definieren Sie dieses erdmittelzeit alt,
plötzlich M&S die Neuzeit letztlich das sind nur die letzten 65 Millionen Jahre da ist alles irgendwie Siegeszug der.
Säuger und Vögel wie wir sie kennen heute und diese alt.
Die Paläozoikum das sozusagen primitive Ratner da habe ich Dir entdeckt Insekten entwickeln der gabski das Carbon ist ein eine Einheit davon da gab's diese Riesen Kohle Werder in der unsere Steinkohle entstanden ist divers,
heute nutzen ja und in der Zeit gab es eine recht sauerstoffhaltige Atmosphäre da gab's diese Rieseninsekten so Meter langer Tausendfüßler und die bellen und so.
Der geschichtsverbund aber gerade in dieser alten Zeit gab es auch ein paar aussterbeereignisse wo man,
bis jetzt nur spekulieren kann dass der auch wieder kosmische Ereignisse rein gespielt haben also sicher der ein oder andere Meteoriteneinschlag den wir einfach heute nicht mehr nachvollziehen können z.b. wenn sie malt Meteorit ins Meer fällt.
180 Millionen Jahre ist der Weg ist der red schockiert durch die Plattentektonik.
Ja okay.
Eine andere Vermutung habe ich auch mal nett hier drüber geschrieben,
gamma ray burst also zu dieser Ereignisse die wir jetzt mit den Gravitationswellen langsam beobachten können kollidierende Neutronensterne oder Weißer Zwerg Neutronenstern gibt's auch kleinere eigenes entsteht sehr viel Gamma Strahlung.
Innerhalb von Sekunden da denkt dieser dieser gamma ray burst können die Helligkeit von Galaxien überstrahlen in der kurzen Zeitraum und wenn sowas in der Milchstraße in Erdnähe passt oder in der Nähe der Sonne passiert.
Kann es sein dass die zumindest eine Hälfte der Erde gebraten wird gegrillt wird und alles weiß zumindest.
Zumindest an Land unterwegs Hilfe oder mehr ist man dann auch noch geschützt dann ist die Frage ob das wirklich so ein globales Massensterben ist.
Aber da gibt's Vermutung dass bei diesem frühen ausstellbar kistenfleisch sowas noch alle gespielt hat eine Mission die du ja auch schon in Raum Zeit hattest zur zu Geier Mission.
Da könnte man sich mal angucken was da so früher vorbeigeflogen ist ein Stern.
Also ich denke nicht dass man so ganz früher sehr lange zurückliegende Ereignisse damit datieren kann aber zu so zumindest zu die letzten paar Millionen Jahre.
Ist durchaus möglich zwei zu gucken was für große Sterne da vorbeigekommen sind bajaga ja quasi sternposition vermisst.
Im Orbit um das Zentrum der Milchstraße und wenn man die Bewegung und Orbitz beschrieben hat kann man die auch mal zurückdrehen Umrechner und mal schauen.
Achso.
Stern in welchem Zustand wann wo wohl gewesen ist und ob zu dem Zeitpunkt ein Ereignis hat es stattgefunden hat.
Genau also ich weiß nicht ob das dann irgendwann geowissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse überführt werden kann das müsste man sicher dann verknüpfen mit Erkenntnissen aus dem Gestein.
Na also seiner sich bitte die die großen Umwälzungen waren halt vermutlich ja extern getriggert mit brütenden Einschläge oder eben auch solche Strahlen Einschläge.
Von der von dem er noch keine klare Kenntnis haben aber könnte ja passieren dass uns irgendwie auch mal so ein Blitz trifft aber die Erde mal geblitzt.
Das Wasser jakal zwei wilde Reise jetzt hier irgendwie,
durch die Zeit sicherlich auch eine ganze Menge wo man hier später noch mal anknüpfen kann der ganze Bereich der Evolution und des Lebens,
liegt vielleicht noch nicht ganz so im Fokus von Raumzeit aber auf jeden Fall ist natürlich sehr interessant,
dadurch dass man um die auf die Erde selber mal blicken auf die Nachbar Planeten auch besser zu verstehen wie unser Sonnensystem eigentlich entstanden ist und so dick.
Ich finde auch bisschen schade eigentlich das so in der Berichterstattung über Raumfahrt und Erkenntnisse aus der Exploration des Sonnensystems zu dieser geologische Blickwinkel,
seltene Rolle spielen also es ist mal also Raumfahrt ist irgendwie so.
Ja Raumsonde Technik Komplex Instrumente bei bei Mars-Rover curiosity irgendwie hier der skycrane mit den das Ding abgesetzt wird das ist alles.
Plakativ.
Plakativ ja und das begeistert natürlich die Leute auch ich kann es auch verstehen das ist sozusagen hier Risiko und Hollywood artiges ganz und dann machen wir noch ein schönes Video darüber wie gefährlich das alles ist und riskant aber,
das worum es eigentlich geht also ich meine,
es ist ja auch innerhalb der Missionen so das ist gerade in der Phase wo man darüber berichtet wollen wir Techniker das Sagen haben und die Wissenschaftler das ist ein.
Kleiner Teil der Leute die am Sonnabend der nehmung beteiligt sind wenn man alle zusammen in von der Trägerrakete über
die ist das Steuern von dem Ding dabei Rosetta habe gesehen das Steuern war irgendwie wahnsinnig aufwendig so ein Camp Kometenkern zu umkreisen und das hat mir hinzubekommen dann landen wir da und Zimmer noch nie gemacht und.
Und der Geologe der am Ende die daten kriegt er ist dann irgendwie die medial Lupe weg ne also da gibt's dann.
1 2 3 15 Jahre später noch studieren wo sich vorstellt das mal angucken aber da ist dann dass das Pferd schon weiter geritten.
Bei der bei der nächsten Raumfahrtmissionen das finde ich ein bisschen schade ich verstehe als Medienmacher warum es so ist aber das.
Würde ich auch gerne irgendwie ändern oder ja mehr zu diesen Themen arbeiten.
Ja macmac geology sexy irgend also meiner ist natürlich schon so dass ich glaube,
hat man sich auch selten klar und ich hoffe dass das hier bei uns hat auch immer mal wieder heraus prefemin dir all diese ganzen Missionen anschaut diese Reisen zu fernen Planeten dieser Aufwand mit der Untersuchung des Kometen
leider ist diese ganze technische Begeisterung oder auch die Begeisterung des,
dieser fortwährenden Prototypen Produktion dass man immer wieder neue Maschinen baut und neue Systeme und Methoden entwickelt um Wort zu ändern,
Körpern fliegen zu können dann Erkenntnisse generierte habe wenn ja sicherlich auch demnächst noch über die neuen Missionen zu Asteroiden etc berichten.
Du bist ja genauso.
Ja ich bin genauso weil das halt interessant ist nur das Ziel dessen das ist ja eigentlich ein anderes weil es geht ja um einen fortwährenden Erkenntnisgewinn das alles zu der Vehikel und,
oft sind es einfach Erkenntnisse die dann letztlich dazu führen dass wir unser ist,
hier auf der Erde besser verstehen können und dadurch dass wir in die Ferne gucken auch besser in unsere eigene Erde schauen können und dadurch eben,
Dinge auch immer wieder besser verstehen können mit Implikation in alle anderen Wissenschaften ja hinein also auch die,
Biologie Evolution etc
sie hat ja von diesem biologischen Erkenntnissen bekommt auf einmal Erklärung für bestimmte Ereignisse aus dem man dann wiederum andere Schlüsse ziehen kann bis hin in die Medizin hinein und ja insofern,
wann ist ganz angemessen weil die Geologie ganz in den Mittelpunkt zu stellen und vielleicht waren es ja auch noch ein paar andere Themen ein wie man das ganze vertiefen kann.
Aber der Stille soll ich jetzt erstmal danke Karl.
Gerne hat Spaß gemacht.
Für die Ausführungen hier zur geologischen Zeit ja und das war's heute mit Raumzeit gesagt tschüss und bis bald.